dynamic programming is a method for
solving complex Problems by breaking
them down into simpler overlapping sub
problems and storing solutions to these
sub problems to avoid redundant
computations it can help you solve
complex programming problems such as
those often seen in programming
interview questions about data
structures and algorithms Alvin zablin
teaches this course about dynamic
programming in Java he has multiple
super popular algorithm courses and he
is a great teacher
hey programmers Alvin from structure
here Welcome to our course on dynamic
programming in Java this is one of the
most highly requested topics from free
code Camp students so I'm super excited
to explore this material with you in
Java so if you're looking for a really
thorough exploration of dynamic
programming exclusively in Java you're
in the right place of course that means
all of our code specific walkthroughs
are going to be in the Java programming
language as for the format of this
course we're going to build our dynamic
programming knowledge by exploring a
sequence of problems the problems are
going to start simple but it's really
going to give us the foundation we need
to eventually solve some very tough
dynamic programming problems in this
very course for every problem we work
through we're going to solve it using
two steps the first thing we're going to
do is head to my whiteboard where we'll
come up with a strategy and really try
to visualize the dynamic programming
nature Behind these problems so after we
draw things out on the Whiteboard and
get a really confident understanding of
the structure behind a particular
problem then we're going to head into my
editor where we're actually going to
code up a Java specific solution alright
so that's enough introduction for now
what I want to do is hop into our very
for section on our exploration of
dynamic programming we're going to work
through and frame our Fibonacci problem
through our dynamic programming lens
hey programmers Alvin here right now I
want to work through this FIB problem of
course we're referring to the classic
Fibonacci Sequence this is a really
really important you know computer
science problem and to me it serves as
the foundation to really unlocking a few
harder Concepts down the line so even if
you've done this FIB problem before it
helps to review it together right now
we're gonna see this core pattern uh
show up a lot during the course together
and so let's start by understanding what
we should do in this problem well we
know that the Fibonacci sequence has a
few certain seed values we say that the
first number of the sequence is zero and
the second number of the sequence is one
and then to generate further numbers of
the sequence we just take the sum of the
previous two in other words I can take
zero plus one and that gives me the next
number one right so the sequence starts
zero one one then from there I continue
this pattern right I can take the one
plus one that gives me two I can take
the one plus two and of course that
gives me three and so on so forth and of
course I can generate uh the sequence of
infinite length in this way and so
overall in this rendition of Fibonacci
what we want to do is actually return
the number at the specified index of the
sequence right and so a really key
insight about the Fibonacci sequence is
to generate any particular number of the
sequence we must know some other numbers
of the sequence right I can get eight by
just doing the previous three plus five
if I wanted to actually formalize this
problem a little bit better what we'll
have to do is understand that these
numbers I have listed are really the
elements of the sequence
and of course I can assign some indices
to those elements so up top I'll just
label these increasing by one of course
but starting at zero so I can say
something like hey the zeroth number of
the sequence is zero and the first
number of the sequence is one and also
the second number of the sequence is one
and so on and so forth so kind of
jumping ahead a little bit if I look at
this particular position what I see is
all right it seems to be that the
seventh number of the Fibonacci sequence
is exactly 13. that's going to be
overall the shape of this problem
all right so how can we go about solving
this one and so for this particular
approach what I want us to do is
actually work through this one
recursively I think the iterative
solution is pretty straightforward but
I'm going to force us to solve this one
recursively because it's going to help
us I'll learn some new topics along the
way so we'll kind of stick to a
recursive mindset and if you hate
recursion you know too bad he'll learn
to love it right now
and so looking at a particular example
let's say I wanted to figure out how I
can come up with the solution for FIB of
six in other words the sixth Fibonacci
number is exactly eight
and so what I can start to do is figure
out how to break down this problem I
know in general to generate the sixth
number of the sequence I can take the
fifth number and add that to the fourth
number right it's exactly the rule of
the Fibonacci sequence let me try to
visualize this one a little bit better
so I'll represent uh the problem FIB of
six using somewhat of a tree and I'll
represent an instance of the problem as
a note of this tree so I have my top
level problem of six that'll be the root
of this tree and this is a really
important way to actually visualize
recursion because it really shows us how
we're going to utilize our return values
and reconstruct our final answer
so if this is a new pattern for you
don't worry we'll walk through it pretty
slowly together
and so now that I have this root of six
I have to figure out how do I break down
this problem well like we just said to
solve above six what I need to do is
break that down into fibbo five so
that'll appear as a child of that sixth
node in the same way for before also
needs to be solved to solve our main
problem over here and notice how I have
these you know children nodes of course
below the FIB of six right as I go
downward in this tree I should be
getting smaller and smaller numbers in
blue right that would represent a
smaller problem because I know once I
have a small enough input in blue then I
would have somewhat of a base case kind
of inherent the Fibonacci sequence so
let's take a closer look at this five
note over here right this node
represents the problem of FIB of five
right what is the fifth number of the
sequence and I know in general my
pattern is all right if I want to
calculate FIB of n then I take the sum
of N minus 1 and N minus two so I'm just
going to apply that pattern to this five
node in other words on fives left it's
going to have a node of four and a five
is right it's going to have a note of
three right doing a minus one and minus
two respectively and it's a similar
trend for the four node on the right
hand side over here right it's going to
have two children of course doing -1 on
the left and minus two on the right
giving three and two respectively
so let's keep applying this pattern
we're going to do is fill out the next
level of the tree
until we can't fill it out anymore
we have to notice here is when it comes
to actually building on the full tree we
have to stop at certain nodes in other
words once I have an instance like zero
as my input to this little sub problem I
can actually shrink that problem size
any further let's all highlight all of
these nodes whose input is zero right
that represents the zeroth number of the
Fibonacci sequence and something
inherent in the problem is I can't
really break that problem down any
further I know that for those particular
nodes they ought to return zero right
because a zero number of the Fibonacci
sequence is exactly zero so in green I'm
going to represent the result or the
answer to those sub problems right I'm
going to put their answers above the
problem itself right so I'm trying to be
very very particular in my drawing I'm
always going to write a return value
above a node here
and I have a similar case for all of my
nodes who have an input of one those are
also a base case right because the first
number of the Fibonacci sequence is
exactly one so we'll also fill in those
ones above
cool now that I have some floating
return values I can start to reconstruct
my larger problems at hand
so let's stay focused on the left hand
side of my tree let's look at this
particular node so I'm looking at this
node of two and I have a left hand value
and a right hand value are ready to
compute I know that if I look at this
this node of 2 it's trying to figure out
what's the second number of the
Fibonacci sequence and so at this node
of 2 in blue what I can do is just take
the sum of its children right of those
green values so 1 plus 0 gives me one
and if I do a quick Sandy check that
must mean that the second number of the
Fibonacci sequence is exactly one and
this pattern continues up the tree right
at this node of three I take the sum of
the one plus one and I get two if I do a
quick Sandy check that must mean the
third number of the Fibonacci sequence
is two what we're doing right now is
really stepping through how a recursive
code would actually return right return
means return to your caller right so
return to your parent node
and so I'll fill in the rest of the
values over here
and bear in mind you know as you kind of
uh draw out these diagrams maybe for
yourself hopefully on pen and paper or
even on a whiteboard it's really
important at least for me that you check
for correctness as you build the tree so
if you're in an interview it really
helps to not just check for your top
level answer being correct but at any
points of your Trace you should have
logical information in other words by
just looking at this node right I have a
blue note of three over here whose
return value is two that logically
implies that the third Fibonacci number
is two and that's totally correct so I'm
good to go for now right it would really
be a drag if I kind of sketch through
this entire drawing only to realize I
had a little like typo or miscalculation
somewhere Below in the tree so I highly
recommend that you stay very aware of
your sub results as you kind of Trace
through a diagram like this
so let's continue to build up these sub
Solutions
so I know that this node of 2 is going
to take the sum of one plus zero that
gives me one and finally at the parent
of four it's also going to take the sum
so two plus one is three and that must
mean that the fourth of a notch a number
is of course three so let's speed this
up a little bit for every other uh node
in the tree
so we're gonna add all these up
so on and so forth
now at the tippy top we see that this
note of six at the root is going to take
the sum of five and three and of course
that gives me eight which is exactly the
punch line right the sixth Fibonacci
number is indeed eight and so looking at
this pretty large tree you might realize
that hey you know our top level problem
was asking for the sixth Fibonacci
number not a very large number in the
sequence however we have to use a lot of
nodes to actually represent that problem
how we broke it down that's something
really important about this Fibonacci
Sequence right it has a pretty
interesting complexity a pretty large
one at that so let's try to analyze the
complexity of this we know that every
node of this like visual tree represents
a recursive call right and so the number
of recursive calls I make over here or
the number of nodes of the tree should
roughly represent the time complexity of
this solution you're probably already
recognizing that it's going to be a very
very large one
let's go step by step over here and so
to analyze the complexity of recursion
like this I think it's really important
to notice any patterns in the tree to me
it's all about looking in the tree right
I can kind of figure out at least the
ballpark of the type complexity without
even writing the code right just using
this visual
and so at first glance you might notice
that this one is pretty hard to analyze
because the tree is asymmetric in other
words notice that it's a little taller
or deeper on the left hand side then
toward the right hand side of the tree
it's actually much more shallow and that
kind of asymmetry makes us feel a little
uncomfortable when it comes to figuring
out any patterns so here's what we'll do
let's actually try to analyze this one
by drawing an analogy so let's ignore
this exact Fibonacci tree right now and
go for a more symmetric example so let's
say I had a similar recursive code that
had a more symmetric recursion so let's
say I had some top level call with a
value of four and let's say that this
top level call to four I actually made
two more recursive calls but both on a
minus one in other words the left child
is the same as the right child which is
different from our classic Fibonacci
right Fibonacci our left was minus one
and our right was minus two but now I'm
just doing minus one on both sides if I
continue that pattern that should give
me a nice symmetric tree let's say I had
some base case roughly when my value is
one so I can stop building the tree from
here
and so this has a nice symmetry to it
let's try to notice any patterns now
if I look at the different levels of
this tree let me look at how many nodes
there are across a level so for example
my very very top level and there's one
note on that level on the next level
there's two nodes and then four nodes
and then eight nodes you can probably
see how this pattern scales right if I
drew more of this tree let's say I had a
farther a base case it would be 16 nodes
and then 32 nodes and so on
and so you probably realize the obvious
pattern here right the very top at the
root of my you know recursive tree I
have one note or one call and then from
one level to the next I doubled I
multiply by two right and I do this
process basically for every level of
this tree so that begs the question you
know how many levels are there in this
tree well just looking at this kind of
particular concrete example there's
definitely about four levels right and I
can kind of understand uh how to
designate each level by just looking
along this left-hand path right so
colored in yellow notice that I have
four three two one that's just a
decreasing pattern
so when it comes to the number of levels
it's pretty obvious to me that it's
exactly n levels right if my top level
problem at the root is where n equals
four then I have you know four levels or
in general n levels
so it's pretty clear to me that when it
comes to figuring out the total number
of nodes in this tree which implies the
total number of recursive calls we make
for this kind of toy problem it looks
like I would multiply two by itself n
times over which is a definition of an
exponential 2 to the nth power
cool so maybe you're a little bit
skeptical and here's where we can either
you know really buy into kind of the Big
O complexity or we can get bogged down
by the finer details something that you
might fall into sometimes but you have
to kind of be very aware of it is Big O
is really just an estimate so if you
actually plug in some values here you
might notice all right if I did 2 to the
fourth power right because 4 is my n in
this particular example that would be
16. and so if we actually counted the
quantity of nodes in this visual tree it
would not be exactly 16. I'll label them
over here starting at one there's
actually going to be 15 nodes so it's
off a little bit but if we you know
understand Big O complexity we know that
if we have something that's of the shape
of like 2 to the N minus 1 we can ignore
the minus one what's more is even if it
was off by like five right if it's a
minus five that's still a constant that
we're subtracting that still is dropped
from the Big O notation so overall I
would consider this particular example
as having o of the 2 to the N Run time
which would be exponential pretty pretty
slow right
so while we're here looking at this
symmetric example before we hop back
into FIB let's try to recognize what the
space complexity is we know how the
space complexity for recursive code is
going to be more or less the number of
Stack frames that we use right for our
recursion because whenever we make a
recursive call that information has to
be stored on the call stack right so we
kind of make different function calls
and also return from function calls
and so this is actually something I
notice students have quite a difficult
time uh analyzing and so what I'm going
to do is really Trace through how we
would make these recursive calls as well
as how to visualize the call stack right
so this top level call of four that
would be added to the stack all right so
stack will be just a little a little
rectangular block right and then as I
make recursive calls let's say now I
call upon three that's my input that's
also added to the stack notice that it's
added on top of the four right and
really we have to recognize here is
every time we make a call we're adding a
new stack frame and we only get to
remove something from the call stack
when it returns so so far none of my
calls have returned right until I have
one at the top of my stack right at this
point I've kind of bottomed out at like
a base case so I can return from that
call which also means I remove it from
the stack
at this point I need to evaluate two's
right child so I make another call to
one
and this process continues right now I'm
done with both of twos call so it can
return
now I'm back at three but three has to
call upon it's right
and the same thing happens well you'll
notice that at this point is although
there are many you know different stack
frames we would have to eventually push
onto the call stack at any point in time
there's only about a four different
stack frames on the call stack right
it's not as if that we store like all of
these different stack frames
simultaneously right it doesn't really
make any sense to add certain stack
frames you must have returned from other
ones so it's actually the case that the
space complexity due to the call stack
would just be o of n overall we're
looking at an exponential runtime and a
linear space complexity alright so for
this particular symmetric example it has
an exponential runtime and a linear
space complexity but how about for our
actual Fibonacci tree we know our
Fibonacci tree is more lopsided
it's roughly going to be like half the
size of that and you can take my word
for it it would actually be the same Big
O complexity right still 2 to the n and
then just an O of n space complexity
and so kind of taking a lay the land
over here the space complexity seems
reasonable right however whenever we
have an exponential usually that's not
good enough and there is actually a
better or faster way to solve this one
recursively which is what I want to
expose this to uh right now so let's go
back to the recursion tree for our FIB
problem right and so what we can do is
try to recognize any patterns within
this tree do you notice any duplicate
work right this is all about
understanding you know what this diagram
represents right every node I have drawn
in here with its corresponding number
represents a problem
as you can see I have many duplicate
problems so for example if I look at
this subtree that sub tree represents a
sub problem right rooted in four so I'm
asking for the fourth Fibonacci number
not only do I need to calculate that on
the left hand side of the tree but at
some other point down the line on the
right hand side I need to calculate that
same exact sub problem right these two
subtrees are identical
and they both represent the same problem
the fourth Fibonacci number
and this pattern actually applies
recursively because the strategy is
recursive right so you can notice
probably some other different duplicate
sub problems right if I root myself at
three I have to calculate this sub tree
three different times right and notice
that that three subtree is also internal
uh to the fit before so it's a really a
really duplicate and there are a few
other duplicate sub trees you can
recognize over here so we have a lot of
duplicate work in this kind of Brute
Force recursion
and if we actually store some sub
results then we can forego having to
recalculate any of these subtrees down
the line
and so really what we're looking to do
is kind of prune out some branches of
this tree to avoid some duplication so
what I'm going to do is kind of ignore
this right hand tree of four so I'm
going to take that out because I would
have calculated it on the left hand side
somewhere I'll do the same thing for
this kind of middle tree of three so I
can ignore that as well
cool likewise for this too
and so at this point we don't really
have any full duplicate sub trees right
I kind of took them out of my drawing
so if we actually store some results as
we calculate these sub problems this
really represents all of the recursive
calls that we'll have to make right and
so you're wondering how can I actually
Implement you know that kind of pattern
in my code well it's all about just
storing some additional information so
let's step through still FIB of six so I
want the six Fibonacci number in the
long run we should get eight and the
strategy I'm introducing right now is
called memoization and so when it comes
to implementing memoization in your
language of choice it's all about
storing some additional data in a memo
and your memo is typically going to be
your like hashed data structure so it
could be like a hash map or a dictionary
or object depending on your weapon of
choice here right it's really important
that I choose some data structure that
gives me an O of one lookup time right
so usually that would be your hashed
data structures whatever that is in your
particular language
and so let's step through this one again
but now we're going to store some data
inside of our memo so we have the same
base cases as before right we know that
the first Fibonacci number is one and
the zero Fibonacci number is zero and
when these values return to the parent
of two we're still going to calculate
the sum over here so 1 plus 0 is just
one but now that I have this result I
can store it in the memo so I'm going to
make the key represent the input to that
node or that recursive call and then its
value is going to be that return value
and so if I look inside of my memo it's
a reminder that the second Fibonacci
number is one
so we'll continue this process I know
that I have a basically server here
still the case that the first Fibonacci
number is one and I return to the parent
I calculate that hey the third Fibonacci
number is two and I'm going to store
that in my memo as well and here's where
things get a little more interesting if
I look at this node of 2 over here I've
actually calculated uh this sub problem
before right I can check that by just
looking inside of my memo my memo says
Hey the second Fibonacci number is one
so without having to recurse and build
the full subtree once again I'll just go
ahead and fetch on the stored value in
my memo so I'm just going to jot down a
one above this node of two I'm not going
to return to my parent and I figure out
that hey the fourth Fibonacci number is
three and of course I want to be sure to
return that but also store it in my memo
for the future
and same thing happens at this three
note right this three note is again in
my memo so without you know re-cursing
through my tree I'm going to just fetch
that value from my memo I already know
that hey the third Fibonacci number is
two and so I can calculate the value at
my parent right fifth for Notch number
is five be sure to store that in your
memo and so on and so forth by the time
we get to the very top of our tree of
course we have the fact that the six
Fibonacci number is indeed eight and I
avoided a lot of the duplicate recursive
calls
so it's clear to me that we avoid a lot
of duplicate work what exactly is the
run time now right and so we'll try to
notice uh some patterns so this visual
tree represents our Fibonacci recursion
after we implement this memoization
strategy right I'll try to generalize it
over here so I'll kind of tidy up these
edges over here
and let's say I increased the size of
this problem so instead of FIB of six
what if I asked you for FIB of seven
that recursion tree would look something
like this
right notice that the root is now seven
of course and it's still the case that
the left child is -1 so a six and the
right child of the seven is a minus two
or a five right still being the rules of
Fibonacci and I only added two more
nodes if I increase the problem size to
FIB of eight I would still add two more
nodes
so every time I increase my input by one
I only add two nodes it's always adding
a constant number of nodes at this point
our problem scales linearly right
in general we're going to notice that we
have basically two times n nodes and
notice that that's not 2 to the N where
I'm saying 2 times n and so we can
simplify that to a runtime of O of N and
the space complexity is still the same
right notice that the space complexity
for this algorithm is really just going
to be the height of the visual tree it
still looks like a linear chain right if
I go along the left-hand path it just
goes eight seven six five four and so on
so definitely an O of n space complexity
and this is actually a pretty efficient
solution for our Fibonacci and so I
think from this point let's go ahead and
implement this in some code now we can
have this core pattern under our belts
so I highly recommend that you try to
implement this one in some code on your
own but don't forget we also have the
video walkthrough available if you get
stuck or just want to code along
now that we're done sketching out a
strategy for this problem on the
Whiteboard what you want to do is follow
the link in the description for this FIB
problem so you can follow along and code
up our solution in Java with me
hey programmers Alvin here what I want
to do right now is go over the Java
walkthrough for this FIB problem this is
going to be our very first problem in
the dynamic programming section now I am
going to teach you to solve dynamic
programming problems is using recursion
plus memoization so we're going to start
just by warming up here and solving this
Fibonacci problem uh using recursion and
then we're going to apply our
memoization strategy on top of it and
this is going to be a really great
strategy that can scale to a lot of
different dynamic programming problems
obviously you might be thinking that you
could solve a Fibonacci using some you
know pretty classic iterative code and
you definitely can however I'm going to
show you how to solve this recursively
with memorization because it's really
going to set you up for harder problems
later on so let's Jump Right In when it
comes to setting up the recursive code
here I want to start with my base cases
and they tell us that the zeroth number
the Fibonacci sequence is zero and the
first number of the Fibonacci sequence
is one so I'll turn those into base
cases so I can just go ahead and check
hey if n equals zero then I know I need
to return zero like wise if n is equal
to 1 I know I want to return one
so to kind of combine those into a
single base case here I can check if n
equals zero or n equals one well there's
return n itself right because the zeroth
number of the sequence is zero and the
first number of sequence is one and
that'll give me my two base cases to
start then from there I only need one
more line of code the recursive
definition of Fibonacci is to get some
further a number of the sequence you
just take the sum of the previous two
right so I know that the previous number
of the sequence would be Fibonacci of n
minus one right because n represents the
number I'm asking for so the number in
the sequence that comes before would be
n minus 1. I want to add that
to Fibonacci of n minus two right so
that would be the number two steps ago
right take the sum of them and that
would give me my current number
so let's give that a test run
this will be correct but it won't scale
in terms of the time complexity like we
said in the approach video the time
complexity of this Fibonacci function
although it's very short code is
exponential right it's 2 to the n and so
the growth of this function as we
increase the input number n is very very
large so you're actually going to get a
timeout for this one
and so to make this faster we're going
to layer on a memoization strategy right
and so what's really important in the
way I teach monetization is we always
start by solving the brute force and
here I have the Brute Force right I can
identify that I've correctly implemented
The Brute Force when I get correct
results for my method except it's slow
right so it times out for some very
large input for example if I take a look
at the test case I'm feeling right now
it would be calling Fibonacci with an N
of 46 right it would give me some large
value and because this has an
exponential time complexity that's far
too large for me to wait around for
and so when it comes to creating a
memoization around this Brute Force
solution in Java what I usually do is
create two separate methods I'll have my
main method I also have my recursive
helper method that also takes in a memo
and so let me create another version of
this method above
that would be the main method and it's
just gonna really call and pass control
into my recursive method
I'm going to overload it with an
additional argument here right so FIB
the recursive method is going to take in
not only the integer n but my memo and
for you in Java it'd be nice if you
implement your memo using a fast lookup
data structure right because you want to
improve the runtime of this code so you
want to store your sub results in a fast
lookup data structure so for you that
could be as simple as a hash map so I'm
going to import up top
Java util
hashmap
so I know that a hashmap has o of one
insertion and ov1 lookup
and I'll take in a hash mark over here
and when it comes to how I design the
structure of the hash map I know that
the keys of my hashmap need to be input
arguments to My Method here right so I
know the input argument is a number or
integer n so I'm going to make the key
integer
I make the corresponding value in the
hash map the return value for my method
it's going to have integer values as
well I'll just call this argument memo
so that means when I in my main function
call my recursive method here I'll pass
in the original n but I'll give it a new
hash map
nice I could just return whatever the
recursive method returns so do bear in
mind that this circus of method now line
9 is taking in my original argument n as
well as this memo hashmap right and this
memo hashmap is going to be shared for
the entire recursion right so what I
need to be sure to do is I'm taking in
the memo that's an argument here when I
call recursively on FIB I want to pass
along the same memo
right you're passing it by reference so
you can have all of your recursive calls
share the same memo object right think
of it as if when you visualize like the
recursion tree like we did in our
approach video you want all of your
nodes in the tree to refer to the same
memo
awesome
so that's just me adding an additional
argument into FIB but now I actually
want to use that memo object
and so what you should do is check if
your argument is already a key in your
memo right so I'm going to check it over
here it kind of acts like another base
case here so I put it at the top so I'm
going to check if my memo already
contains
key of my argument n
right
what I can do is then just return the
stored value of that key so I can do
memo dot get n
obviously this only works if I you know
over time store values into my memo
which I'll do in a moment right so I
know my memo is going to map right
arguments
of my method to their return values so
if I find an argument in the memo that
matches my current argument I'm just
going to return its stored value in the
memo
but that means I need to be storing
things over time into the memo and so
now you should locate wherever you
return recursively for your method so
that'd be the line 19 return right those
are my recursive return values right I
know that line 11 is not a recursive
return value because it's literally my
base case right so I know that this
value here I know it's really composed
of you know two separate or cursive
calls but I know that this will
ultimately evaluate to a number right
and we're turning a number here that
number is like the answer so what I'll
do is I'll save it in a variable
I'll just call it result
and you know that this result is going
to be the answer for Fibonacci of n so
what I want to do is in my memo before I
leave I want to store
using the key of n
I want to make the corresponding value
this result again what I'm doing here is
I'm making sure my memo Maps arguments
of my method to their return values
I know the answer for like FIB of n is
this result
and what you want to be sure to do is
just complete the return value like
before so I just want to return result
so I'm still returning the same data as
before I'm just additionally storing
into a memo for later on
and what's great is later on you know
somewhere in your recursion when you
encounter an N that you've seen before I
mean you know that's going to happen in
this problem because we you know demoed
it in the approach video when you see an
input and you want to evaluate an input
and that you've seen before then you'll
actually hit this base case on line 14.
you're going to find that that argument
is already in the memo and you're just
going to return the stored value inside
and that happens in constant time right
because I know getting you know from a
hash map is constant time so with that
change let's go ahead and give this a
test run
really important thing to remember to do
is be sure to pass your memo you know to
your recursive calls over here that way
you get that shared information across
all of your recursive calls awesome and
there we have it so by implementing this
memoization strategy on top of our Brute
Force we really improve the time
complexity of this solution right like
we said in the approach video now we're
looking at an O of n runtime right space
complexity is also going to be o of n
because we have to store all of these
calls on the call stack and even if we
consider the size of our memo we know
that our memo is just going to have a
number of entries that could be at most
equal to our input n right because I'm
using my input n as the keys of my hash
map and I know that keys are unique all
right programmers so what I want you to
do is take a moment really be sure to
redo this problem and understand how we
solved it in two steps right first I
solve just the Brute Force recursion and
then I apply my memoization on top of it
this is going to be a really really
important pattern moving forward we're
going to scale it to solve some pretty
interesting and difficult uh dynamic
programming problems but I always
follows this core pattern of solving a
Brute Force recursion then additionally
adding a memo hash map to it I'll do a
variation of this in the next video I'll
see you there
hey programmers Alvin here right now I
want to show you the approach for this
Fibonacci problem and so I know you're
thinking you know why is he having us do
basically a ripoff of Fibonacci well I
think it's really important that if you
want to get good at these algorithm
things then you have to have a certain
level of repetition as the saying goes
one is none right so even though you
know we've just done another Fibonacci
problem doesn't mean that it's
completely something that we've mastered
so if anything this should be a quick
little review right of course I want you
to solve this tribonacci problem uh
recursively
and so let's take a look at the sequence
so here is a few numbers of the
Fibonacci sequence all you'll notice is
in this particular problem like before I
want you to give me back a particular
number of the sequence so imagine that
we had corresponding indices for each of
these numbers
when it comes to the tribonacci sequence
we're going to have three separate base
cases right the zeroth number of the
sequence is zero and also the first
number of the sequence is zero and the
second number of the sequence is one so
with those three seed values we can come
up with our general rule right just like
before to calculate a number of the
sequence or the next number of the
sequence you just take the sum of the
previous three numbers right or in
general to calculate trip of n you do
the sum of N minus one n minus two and N
minus three and there you'll have your
final answer right it's kind of jumping
at a particular spot within the sequence
if I took the sum of 4 plus 7 plus 13
that would give me exactly 24. so you
should feel red at home in this
particular problem
so let's start to draw this one now I
don't want to skip any steps
and so before we start building this one
let's have some foresight and figure out
how to visualize a problem like this
right and what's great about visualizing
it is at least if we spend some time you
know sketching out you know a structure
of the problem like visually it can also
help us figure out the complexity of
this particular problem
so right now I want to step through
calculating the fifth number of the
sequence which should be four in the
long run so like before I'm going to
represent an instance of this problem
just with a tree and so my top level
problem will be the root of this tree I
want to find a trip of five
and I know that I have to break this
problem down into three sub problems
right in other words I can generate
three children by doing a minus one
minus two and minus three respectively
I'm just going to carry over that
pattern for as many nodes as I can and
of course whenever I hit like a base
case I can't break that node down any
further we know that when it comes to
our tribonacci problem we have three
separate base cases right representing
these particular return values so I'm
just going to plug in these sub results
so I should have all of these calculated
values right zeroth number is zero first
number is zero and also the second
number is one
now I can start reconstructing my sub
Solutions right so if I take a look at
the particular uh to the left the three
node I take the sum of its three
children one plus zero plus zero gives
me one right so the third Fibonacci
number is one and I'll just continue
this pattern right every parent node
just takes the sum of its three children
return values
so I get values that look like this and
finally at the root I just take the sum
of two plus one plus one which gives me
a final answer of 4 right very similar
to our classic a fib problem so this
would be a working solution basically
just doing the same a recursive code
except we're going to have three
recursive calls which makes sense
because every call we make corresponds
to a branch that we have in this visual
tree however
what's the complexity of this one it's
pretty pretty slow for the same reasons
our Fibonacci code was slow before right
so take a look at this particular tree I
can derive the time complexity of it
because I know that for my recursive
code the time complexity is at least
going to be the number of recursive
calls that I make And if every recursive
call corresponds to a note of this tree
I have to figure out what the long term
pattern for the number of nodes is in
this recursion tree so I know that the
height of this tree is pretty obvious
looks like it's going to be along the
order of N and how do I know that well
if you look along the left-hand path it
just goes five four three two and in
general that's roughly N Things right
now just think about how many nodes are
across on every level at the top level
there's one node and to get to the next
level I multiply it by three I continue
this pattern right as a tree gets bigger
and bigger from one level to the next I
would continue by tripling the number of
nodes right very similar to our
Fibonacci problem and so you guessed it
the complexity of this is 3 to the N so
an exponential but with a base of three
right and it is a case that our space
complexity is a pretty reasonable o of n
right of course we're referring to the
space complexity due to the call stack
right and in general we can figure out
the space complexity from the call stack
if we draw out the tree and we can just
look at the height of the tree the
height of the tree being basically the
number of levels and there's roughly you
know four levels here so I guess it's
off by one even though our input was
five right
so to make this one a little faster of
course we can just notice any duplicate
sub problems right so same story like
we're used to look at this sub tree
rooted in three I have this sub tree
appearing here as well and so I want to
avoid resolving that sub problem we're
going to use the same scratch as before
but this I want to use a different word
to describe it really what we're
utilizing here is dynamic programming so
dynamic programming is really a type of
problem solving where we utilize any
overlapping sub problems right in other
words I have this sub problem of
calculating the third tribonacci number
and if I can store that information the
first time I solve that problem I can
utilize it later on because I'm probably
going to encounter that same sub problem
all right so this is in the family of a
dynamic programming strategies and so
far we've been working with memoization
so really memoization is just one way we
can Implement dynamic programming and so
if we use dynamic programming wisely we
should be able to forego that duplicate
subtree right
and overall we'd be looking at an O of n
runtime and O of n space complexity if
we implemented that correctly
right and so to implement that of course
we're going to use some hash data
structure to build that memo so for my
python people you're going to use like a
dictionary for my JavaScript people
you're going to use an object for my
Java people I'm going to use a hash map
right any fast lookup data structure and
at this point we have a pretty optimal
solution for this tribonacci sequence
right it should be able to run in a
pretty decent time and so with that what
I want you to do is I give this code a
shot on your own but don't forget if you
get stuck we do have a Code walkthrough
available as well so give it a go
now that we're done sketching out this
tribonacci problem on our whiteboard
what you want to do is head down to the
links in description and click on the
tribonacci link that way you can follow
along and code up the Java solution with
me
hey programmers welcome back right now I
want to go over the Java walkthrough for
this Fibonacci problem
so it's going to be another dynamic
programming problem just to kind of ease
us into the core pattern that I'm trying
to teach you guys in this course and
that'll help you solve almost any
dynamic programming problem
and so this is going to be a variation
Alpha Fibonacci just called Fibonacci
it's really the same pattern except to
generate a further number of the
sequence you need to use the sum of the
previous three numbers and here I'll
start with my base cases right I know
the Fibonacci sequence has some
different seed values we see that the
zeroth and first numbers are both zero
right so I'm going to actually just go
ahead and jump right in here I'll start
with that as my base case I'm going to
solve this one for now with a Brute
Force recursion
so I'm going to check hey if my n is
zero or my n is one well the 0 and 1
elements of the sequence how about zero
so I return 0 in either case
then additionally I need another base
case if n is two I return the number one
really just arbitrary values for this
sequence here so if n equals two
and return the value of one those would
be my two base cases when it comes to
creating the recursive
case here you just take the sum of the
last three numbers of the sequence so
for me that's as simple as I take the
tribonacci of n minus one and I add that
to tribonacci of n minus 2.
and also add a 2 triple Notch of n minus
three
cool so let's give that a test run this
is a really important step never ever
skip it right whenever you're solving a
dynamic programming problem using
memorization you ought to solve it Brute
Force first and verify that your code is
correct for me correct means that I
always get a correct result for my
method right a timeout is okay right
eventually if we had more time all right
to use up here you would be able to pass
test k07 you will get the correct answer
but this code is just far too slow as it
is right so now that I've verified that
okay this code is just a matter of speed
right it's just slow I can add
memoization on top of it so just like
before
for you and job I think the best way to
solve this one the structure of code is
to overload this method and your
recursive method your brute force is now
going to take in a new argument
it's going to be a hash map and when it
comes to how I set up the keys and
values keys are going to be the
arguments here method here I just have a
single argument n so I'll make that an
integer key
the corresponding return value is going
to also be an integer so it's going to
have integer value
I like to call it memo awesome from
there in my main method you just want to
delegate to your recursive Helper and
you should pass in you know a new hash
map instance here so at the top I should
import the right
thing here so I'll import Java util hash
map
and you can pass it in inline be sure
instantiated here so new hash map
awesome and now when it comes to my
recipe for memorization I have the Brute
Force I'll start by adding a base case
that checks if my key or my input
argument is already in the memo so I'll
add over here along my base cases
I'll say if my memo
contains the key of n
right and if it's there that means I
would have also stored the value that is
the answer for that input n
I'm just going to return whatever that
stored answer that stored value is I'll
do memo dot get and in that case
awesome so I have the logic that looks
into my memory like my memo fetching
logic now I need my memo insertion logic
right so now I need to locate my
recursive return value right this is
where I return the final answer for n
right this would be a number technically
I'm going to store it to a variable
call it result and before I leave and
return the result I actually want to
store that result into my memo so I
actually do memo dot put
and you should always
use the key that's your current input
argument right so this result is the
answer for Fibonacci of n right because
I'm returning it for a call to n and so
n is going to be my key here right so
I'll do n I'll make the value the result
a very important design choice that we
make when we solve our memoization this
way is we're only going to memoize our
current call right so in other words all
of my memo keying happens with the
argument n right I check if it contains
n and if it doesn't then I put a new key
of N I don't write any like awkward
heavy-handed logic like doing memo dot
put I try to Cache like n minus 1 with
some subresult right that gets very very
messy right because we're solving this
recursively if we handle
all of the memoization for our argument
n then everything else will actually be
memorized as well right because you know
that for this particular call when we
jump in and evaluate that call
recursively this n minus one Whatever
actual number that is that is an n in
some other frame of reference right so
you're only going to want to memorize to
keep your code very clean adjust your
current argument n right don't try to do
any of like the the sub problems with
the children here
awesome
and one final thing to do if I actually
test this it's a very common mistake it
won't actually be any faster that's
because these calls are Fibonacci in my
recursive case they need to actually
refer to my overloaded method here which
takes in my memo I obviously I want to
share this memo hash map for the entire
recursion tree here
so I'm going to add that into the mix
just pass along the memo
and that should do the trick
awesome and there we have it
hey programmers Alvin here right now
let's go over the approach for this some
possible problem
so this probably want to take in two
arguments we're going to be given a
amount as well as a array filled with
numbers and we want to do is return true
or false indicating whether or not we
can use some numbers of the array to
generate the amount by adding them
together in this particular example I
should return true because I can totally
make 5 by adding up some numbers in the
array there are a few different ways to
do that I could have done two plus three
or three plus one plus one we're also
two plus one plus two and there are
actually a whole bunch of other
different ways you can sum up to five
but since I have at least one way to
generate five I'm going to return true
so overall we're just looking for a
Boolean return type for a function here
it could be the case that based on the
inputs we're given it might not be
possible so if I gave you a Target
amount of 15 and I gave you numbers to
choose from like 6 4 and 10 that would
actually be impossible so you should
return false all right so how do we
start attacking this one we'll step
through an example where you want to
generate a Target amount of four and we
have numbers one two and three this
should be a sufficiently large example
to step through here my intuition tells
me that smaller amounts are easier to
calculate late than larger amounts so
what I can do is try to shrink my amount
as much as possible until I get to a
trivially small amount for which I know
the answer for so let's say I start with
my amount of four what options do I have
here well if I think about my first
choice what I could do is take a one so
this one is going to represent the first
number I can choose right and what I can
do from there is actually subtract that
one from the four that would give me a
new amount of three
but still at the four note over there
what I can do is also maybe consider
taking a two
if I do 4 minus 2 then my next minus 2.
and the final option would be taking a
3. if I do 4 minus 3 that'd give me one
and at this point I'm starting to shrink
my problem size so inside of the nodes
in blue we're going to have listed the
amount that we're trying to break down
and then the numbers in yellow on the
edges represent the choice of numbers
that we choose we're starting to shrink
our problem size so let's say we took a
look at the three note on the left we
can break it down further right using my
options of one two and three and that
would yield two one and zero
respectively if I take a look at this
two note over here in the middle I have
to watch out because I can only use some
of my numbers for valid moves right in
other words I can do two minus one or
two minus two and that'll give me a one
and zero respectively but what I should
not do is 2 minus three right although I
have a third option of doing a three
that would be too large right now and
that would actually bring me to a
negative quantity so we're gonna need to
watch out for that in our drawing as
well as when we implement the code
similarly for this right hand note of
one I can only subtract one for it
because using any of the other numbers
would bring me to a negative quantity so
I'll continue this pattern for all of
our nodes until we can't break them down
any further and this would be the
complete tree really what we're
describing is the decision tree for all
of the options that we can possibly make
right so although I'm saying tree here
I'm really referring to the fact that
we're breaking this problem down
recursively we go ahead and implement
this we're not going to have to build
any like tree data structure but we're
going to solve it using recursion right
I use this tree as a way to actually
understand all the options I can take
so since we know that this tree
visualizes the recursion or where can we
locate the base case well that would
really be just the leaves of this tree
what we can do is recognize that we have
a bunch of zero nodes over here and to
me that would be a trivially small
amount that I can always know the answer
for so that's going to be my base case
right in other words if someone gave me
an amount of zero I'm just going to
return true why does that make sense
well I can always generate Zero by just
taking no elements of the numbers array
I can always return true regardless of
what numbers you give me you can even
give me no numbers and that'd be totally
fine I can still generate Zero by taking
none of those numbers and so what I'll
do is jot down this return value above
all of my zero nodes those are going to
be my base cases right my base case
calls and I know that if I see a single
true anywhere in the tree then it should
be possible to generate the amount
obviously here we can't really go wrong
and we have a lot of different ways to
generate the amounts if you look within
this tree not only do you know that
there are a bunch of different ways to
make our amounts of four but you can
actually see what numbers you added to
generate that amount for example if I
look at this path
this represents doing a one plus two
plus one to generate four right I'm just
adding the numbers that I have along the
edges here so this tree tells you a lot
of information and you can use it to
solve a bunch of different variations of
this problem so now let's start to look
at how the values return here so given a
parent note if it receives a true from
any of its children then it's also going
to return true so that would evaluate
something like this
until we get a true at the top as our
final answer so far we've described The
Brute Force way to calculate the answer
here I think it's worth going through
the complexity so here I have two
arguments to my function if we say that
a is the amount and N is the length of
numbers you can see that the time
complexity is going to be n to the a
power so this is going to be exponential
so we're doing here is putting n in the
base of the exponent because we know
given a node it's going to give at most
n children because I have to Branch for
every option of number in the numbers
array and I'm putting a in the exponent
because I know that the height of the
tree is at worse going to be a you can
easily see that in this particular
example if you start at the root and
just keep going to the left it goes four
three two one zero which would mean that
the height of the tree in the worst case
is exactly a if I had to keep
subtracting 1 from my node so overall
I'm looking at an N to the a complexity
which is an exponential and typically
going to be too large to actually run
for reasonably large inputs we talk
about the space complexity it's just
going to be o of a right now based on
the heights of our tree right we know
the height of the visual tree would give
us the maximal stack depth so how can we
do better well you should probably catch
the drift by now take a look at this
tree and notice if you see any duplicate
work
what I can notice here is I have some
duplicate subtrees right I can see these
sub trees rooted in two that are
identical and even have smaller sub
trees that are the same like the ones
rooted in one and I know that if I have
duplicate sub trees in this visual that
means I'm trying to solve duplicate
problems right if someone asks me is it
possible to generate two for the first
time then later on if someone asks me
again I should have just memorized that
answer right and so here we're going to
use that memoization strategy just store
some solutions and some cash that way I
can fetch them later on if you
implemented memoization like we've seen
previously then you would be able to
trim out some branches of this tree
ending up with this smaller structure
what would this memoized complexity be
well we'll still say that a is the
amount and N is the length of numbers
what we did was actually remove the
exponential nature of this problem now
we'll say that the time complexity is O
of a times n so it's no longer an
exponent I'm simply multiplying them
right so a still represents the number
of levels within my tree right the
height of the tree and then n represents
the width of my tree right for every
level I will have at most n nodes and it
would still be the case that our space
complexity is O of a we would still use
a a stack frames on our call stack due
to the recursion and in terms of storing
our memo we know that's also going to be
linear in a and when it comes to the
hash map we use to store our memo the
space complexity for that is still going
to be o of a because we're just going to
use every amount every possible amount
as a key of that memo before I let you
go let's step through an amount that
would not be possible given some numbers
so we'll step through a scenario that
should return false so my amount is 15
and I have numbers of 4 6 and 10. if we
attack this one the same way we'll start
with 15 in the root and we'll subtract
each option of number giving us 11 9 and
5 and I'm going to carry this over as
much as I can until I can't reduce my
amount anymore so the full tree will
look like this the nodes highlighted in
red are the nodes that I can't break
down any further because it would bring
me to a negative quantity so if I have
any remaining quantities in those red
nodes then I know that that would mean
those quantities are not possible to be
generated so those should be a base case
that return false now I can evaluate my
returns in the same way as usual right I
just bubble these up to their parents a
parent is going to return true only if
one of its children calls also returned
true but everyone here is false so I'll
get false all the way back up the tree
all right programmers I think that's all
I got for this approach video what you
want to do is possibly give this one a
shot on your own see if you can
translate our visual diagrams into some
code and then if you got stuck you can
find me in the walkthrough videos I'll
see you there
now that we're done drawing up are some
possible solution what you want to do is
head down to the links in description
below where you can find the link to the
some possible problem because we're
going to code up the Java solution right
now together
hey programmers Alvin from structure
here what I want to do is go over the
Java walkthrough for the some possible
problem so you definitely want to make
sure you watch the approach video for
this one this is going to be what I
consider like our first like actually
difficult uh dynamic programming problem
and so those previous toy problems of
like fib and Fibonacci those have all
been building up to a problem like this
right what I really want to emphasize is
we kind of write the code for this is
try to compare the process for solving
it similar to how we solved Fibonacci
and Fibonacci right meaning that we're
going to start by solving just some
Brute Force recursion check that it
works check that it's correct it's
probably going to be too slow and then
we add our memoization on top of it
right we're going to scale out the
solution here
and so let's Jump Right In
and so to solve this one I know I need a
Brute Force recursion and with any
recursion I like to think about my base
cases right so when it comes to my base
cases I have to think about all right
what are some like trivially small
inputs for which I automatically know
the answer like we said in the approach
video The Great base case here is going
to be if your amount is really small so
if my amount is zero
if your amount to zero then what you
want to do is kind of give back a
Boolean representing all right is it
possible to add up numbers such that
their sum is zero and that's always
possible right you're going to always
get a sum of Zero by adding no numbers
together right that's trivially true and
so I'm going to return true here so if
you hit an amount of zero just return
true
awesome but from there I know I have
some positive amount and I need to break
it down smaller and smaller toward this
base case and I know that to shrink the
amount I must subtract some value from
the numbers list so I'm going to start
iterating through the possibilities here
so I'm going to iterate through every
int I'll say none within the numbers
list
and I know that I'm going to take my
current amount and subtract it by this
number so just for some clarity I'm
going to label this variable as my sub
amount right because it's my original
amount just with some number reduced out
of it
awesome and now what I want to do is
keep solving this problem recursively so
now I want to figure out is it possible
to have a sum that adds up to this sum
amount and I have a method to do that
it's the current method I'm writing
right so I'm going to call
some possible and check if the sub
amount is possible Right the second
argument to this recursive method should
be the same argument right numbers you
can reuse the numbers as much as you
want so I can pass in the same numbers
awesome but now recursively have to
think about all right what does this
give back well I know that it definitely
gives back a Boolean and that Boolean
represents whether or not it's possible
to create these sub amount right if it
is possible so if this comes back as
true then I know that it must be
possible to sum up to the entire full
amount so I'm going to return true here
and why does that logically make sense
well if it's possible to make my sub
amount right it must also be possible to
make my full amounts because to make my
full amount I can just add one
additional number to it right because to
get the sub amount in the first place I
took out one valid choice of number but
on the flip side if it's not possible so
if this a recursive call returns false
then you want to keep looking and
consider if another choice of number
would be possible right so something to
watch out for is you don't want to write
like a else return false
right because you would exit too early
right you only want to return true if
you find a valid amount right the place
you should return false is only after
you're done checking every possible
amount and you don't find one right so
you want to write a late return false
here
all right if I don't find any uh sub
amount that's possible and I checked all
of them so after my for Loop then you
can return false hey it must not be
possible to create my amount awesome so
this looks like my Brute Force solution
but we are missing a one kind of glaring
case we'll want to pay special attention
to our subtraction on line 10. right
based on what our amounts and number is
we could get like a negative value for
sub amount imagine my amount is two and
maybe my number is five well if I do two
minus five I get negative three and
things will get kind of nasty from there
because at that point I've already
overshot my base case of zero and so
you'd get increasingly more negative
numbers right as your amount
and so we never really want to let our
amount become negative so I like to turn
that into a base case so if my amount
becomes negative and I can return false
right it's not going to be possible to
create a negative amount using a sum
because they tell us in the problem that
our numbers are all going to be positive
right you can never generate a negative
quantity by summing up positive numbers
awesome so now I'll make sure we don't
overshoot right we'll get just return
false here that'll help us complete
The Brute Force recursive here so let's
give that a shot
always want to make sure that it gets a
correct answer and it just times out
right so now I know that this is a great
candidate for applying memoization right
we know that like we said in the
approach video this currently has an
exponential run time so it's far too
slow
so to structure the
optimize solution here I like to split
up into my main method and my recursive
method that also takes in a new argument
which like we're used to from our last
two problems right it should be a hash
map
cool the keys of the hashmap are just
going to be the argument of My Method
but it's only going to be the argument
that changes right so if I look at the
recursion here I know that amount is
really the argument that changes over
time right the numbers argument or the
list of numbers doesn't change right so
I know that that list of numbers in my
recursion doesn't really dictate the
result right because another changes I
always return based on what the amount
is and so I'm just going to make the
integer amount
my key right the corresponding value is
going to be just the return type of your
method so Boolean here
I know that corresponds with you know
the return values online like 20 and 24
and even in the base case
awesome I'm going to call this my memo
once again
so let me go ahead and do some of the
housekeeping here so I want to
get the hashmap
and when I I'm in my main method I'm
just going to invoke my overloaded
helper method give it the same amount
give it the same numbers but you should
give it a new hash map that's going to
populate over time so it's nice and fast
awesome at this point what I want to do
now is add my base case to check hey
maybe an input amount I've seen before
right so I'm going to add as a base case
here so if my memo
contains a key
that corresponds to the current amount
I'm looking for I just want to return
its stored value because I would have
stored the answer there so return memo
dot get amount all right very
reminiscent of your Fibonacci and
Fibonacci awesome other things I need to
do is need to be sure to pass this memo
by reference to all of my recursive
calls and I know that there are actually
multiple recursive calls here because on
line 25 I have a recursive call and it's
in a loop right so you make a recursive
call for every num of the list
I'm going to over here pass in the memo
and now the only thing I'm missing is I
need to find a way or find a location
where I should add information into the
memo right when do I put some keys and
values into the memo like I said in the
previous videos I always locate my
recursive return values right so that
would be line 26 and line 30 right to be
safe you can memorize both of those
return values right there's no points of
memorizing your base case return values
because those already occur in constant
time right so there's no need to do it
there
so over here before I return true you
want to store in your memo
for the key of amount
the same value would have returned right
so if you return true then your stored
value is true
or if you return false
then in that case your stored value is
going to be false right and like we
always say the key that you kind of
refer to through your entire memo logic
is going to be the argument amount right
so I'm not writing any keys that have to
do with the sub amounts to keep your
code nice and clean you write about your
current amount you're passed in right
you know when you make your recursive
call on the sub amount that will become
its own like full amount and then it
will get cached anyway in the memo so
this should be good to go
let's give this a test run
see how we optimize our solution
great and there we have it
hey programmers Alvin here right now
let's go over the approach for this Min
change problem
so in this problem we want to do is take
in two things as input we're going to be
given a Target amount as well as an
array containing some coin values what
we want to do is return the minimum
number of coins required to create the
amount so for example since my target
amount is 5 one way I can give back five
cents would be to do one plus one plus
one plus one or I can do one plus two
plus two or I could even do one plus one
plus three and also two plus three in
this problem what we want to do is
choose the way that requires the least
number of coins so that would be the two
plus three that would use only two total
coins and my function should just return
that number of coins which would be two
as my final answer all right so let's
start attacking this one by visualizing
it let's sketch out what we would do for
an amount of four that way we can
actually finish it because we're going
to see that as we moderately increase
the amount the size of our problem
actually grows pretty large and so if
you're doing all these problems in order
and I always recommend that you do you
should recognize this one as a dynamic
programming problem so I'm going to try
to do is shrink my problem size then
also notice any overlapping sub problems
in the long run and so I'm going to
sketch things out as a tree what I'll do
in the nodes of my tree is write down my
current amount that I need to generate
and I can break my current amount down
into smaller sub amounts so let's say I
start with 4 at my root to generate
amount to 4 what I could do is use a one
cent coin if I did that my remaining
quantity would be three as my amount I
could have also taken a 2 which case I
need to generate two where I could have
taken the three cent coin in which case
my remaining amount would have been one
so let's continue this pattern let's say
I was at this three node this node would
have three more children just branching
for one cent two cents and three cent
respectively
if I take a look at this two note over
here I can't actually use every option
here I certainly Branch twice because if
I took the three cent coin that would
give me a remaining amount of negative
one which I should probably avoid
similarly for this note of one I can
only Branch using the one cent coin so
let's say we continue this pattern for
the entire tree you would end up with
this structure and what we see visually
is the decision tree that represents
every choice of a coin we can make until
we hit zero and so this is a tree
structure that we've seen a few times in
the course what I'm going to argue is
within the visual of this tree you
should actually be able to recognize
what the answer is for this amount of
four so take a moment see if you can
recognize any properties within this
tree where can I find the answer to this
problem
what we should do is interpret each path
of this tree so let's say I looked at
this path
that would represent the sum of one plus
two plus one in other words I took a one
cent coin and a two cent coin and then
another one cent coin what I can say is
that would represent the answer of three
like a possible answer of three because
I used three coins to generate my target
amount of four that's only one
possibility we know in this problem we
really want the minimal a number of
coins used so that should translate into
one of these shortest paths like this
one
this would represent my sum of three
plus one and that would have a length of
two you could probably notice that there
are a few other paths with a length of
two that's okay we just want to return
the smallest length possible which would
be two and so what we're really
recognizing here is the minimum number
of coins required to generate our amount
would really be the shortest path from
the root to any Leaf within this tree
assuming a leaf terminates at a zero so
how can I do this more programmatically
maybe we'll sketch this out as some
recursion tree right so what I'll do is
think of a return value for all of these
zero nodes
we can say is our base case if our
amount is zero then I should return zero
and so zero is a great choice because
it's a small number and I can't break it
down any further and I should also
return 0 for that instance because the
minimum number of coins required to make
zero sense would be to use zero coins
right just use no coins
so above all of these base case nodes
I'm going to jot down my result of zero
and what I can do is start to evaluate
these as return values so let's say I
was at this node of 1 over here what
I'll do is just receive Zero from my
child call what I should also do is add
1 to it if I add one that would actually
count the edge between myself and my
child node because remember when it
comes to counting the number of coins
we're really counting the number of
edges in a path through this visual tree
so let's say I was at this two node now
I was ready to evaluate it what I do is
receive both of these values of 1 and 0
for my children
and because I want the shortest path or
the minimum number of coins my nodeans
to choose a smaller between the two so I
do one versus zero I pick the smaller
one of zero but then what I need to do
is actually increment that by one to
count the edge between us and what that
would represent this one designates the
shortest way I can make two cents which
would represent this path highlighted in
pink let's continue this pattern so
let's say I was at this one node the
zero would just bubble up then I add one
to it because there's no decision to
make but now it can be at this three
node this three node is going to receive
three options it's going to choose the
smallest among them so just zero but
then it needs to add one to it and at
this point I should be able to check for
correctness I have a green number of one
above my three node which means the
minimum number of coins I need to make
three cents would be just using one coin
which makes perfect logical sense
because I have a three available in my
coins array so I could just take a
single three cent coin let's continue
this pattern elsewhere in the tree
at the root note of four in this tree
it's going to receive a bunch of ones
technically it would choose the smallest
among them which would be a tie given
one and what I should do is always
increment it by one to count the edge
between myself and the children nodes
and this too represents the fact that I
have a few different paths that could
only take two coins or two edges it
could represent this path
or this path or even this path
so as we evaluated this tree something
really important we did was whenever we
received multiple values from our
children so when we received multiple
sub Solutions what I do is choose the
smallest among them right I know I need
some Min value logic present in this
implementation because I want to choose
the minimum number of coins possible so
I'll just keep that in mind when we
implement the code
we talk about the complexity of this
we've seen the structure before right
now we're going to describe the Brute
Force complexity if we say that c is the
length of the coins array and a is the
target amount then the time complexity
is going to be exponential right we know
that the branching factor of this tree
is going to be based on the number of
coins so C right branching Factor refers
to given a node at most how many times
will it yield children and I know what
my ratchet Factor here is three and in
the worst case I have three branches
coming out of a single node
my exponent here is going to be a
because that would be the height of the
tree we'll say that the space complexity
is going to be o of a due to the call
stack because if you look at the height
of this tree it would be in the worst
case a we say the worst case would be
the scenario where I keep taking a bunch
of one cent coins giving me the deepest
recursion possible so if you start the
root node here and you just keep going
left you're going to see a sequence like
four three two one zero and that
definitely is a linear pattern in a so
overall we're looking at an exponential
runtime and a linear space complexity
for this solution the time complexity
definitely needs some work there right
we want to bring it down from an
exponential so like we usually do we
just want to memorize this one we'll try
to notice any duplicate sub problems so
looking at this tree there are some
duplicate sub trees I can notice I can
see these sub trees rooted in two so
instead of recalculating that
subsolution I can save it and just reuse
it so I can trim out that piece of the
tree I also have other sub trees rooted
in one and I can also ignore those right
the way I'll implement this is by using
some constant time data structure like a
hash map I can store sub results as I
compute them in that hash map and then
reuse them later on if that high level
strategy seems confusing don't worry
you'll want to wait until the
walkthrough video will actually show you
the details on how to implement this in
some code
so let's do a re-analysis of this now
we're going to analyze this dynamic
programming solution that uses
memoization the time complexity is just
going to be a times C so it's no longer
exponential it's really a sort of
multi-linear right just multiplying my
two terms together we know that time
complexity is going to be based on the
number of recursive calls we make and in
this visual diagram every node
represents a recursive call we still
have a tree of height a so that's where
the a comes from what we're saying is
across every level of this tree we have
at most C nodes so I think of a as the
height and C is the width that would
give me a times C nodes overall it's
actually pretty easy to spot in this
particular example in the worst case
scenario at a particular level we have
only three nodes at most that's because
our coin array only has three options
inside of it the space complexity for a
solution is just going to be o of a due
to the call stack and we'd be storing at
most a different keys inside of our memo
hash map all right I think I'm ready to
code this one up you want to join me in
the walkthrough video now at this point
we're done with the planning phase for
our Min change solution what you want to
do is head down to the links in
description below where you can find the
link to the Min change problem where you
can code up the solution in Java with me
hey programmers Alvin Constructor here
what I want to do is go over the Java
walk new for this Min change problem so
you definitely want to make sure you
watch the approach video first this is
going to be another dynamic programming
problem similar to our previous some
possible problem like we said in the
approach video what we want to do here
is optimize for the number of coins that
we take into our sum
and so I'll Implement that strategy
exactly what I want to do is start by
laying out a base case we know that in
this problem our base case should be
about an input amount that is trivially
small and for me the amount is going to
be zero so I'm going to check if the
current amount that I'm looking for is
equal to zero then I want to return the
answer for that amount of zero I want to
return an integer representing the
number of coins I need to create that
amount so if someone asked you to
generate zero cents what's the least
number of coins you need to generate
zero cents the answer there is zero
coins so I'm just going to return zero
then from there I want to start writing
my recursive scenarios so I know that I
need to take one of my choice of coins
to reduce the amount so I'm going to
iterate over all the possibilities so
for me that means I'll iterate for every
int coin within the coins list
and what I'm going to do is I'm going to
take the input amount and subtract this
coin from it
that smaller quantity that'll give me my
sub amount we'll call it and from there
I want to recursively find the minimum
number of coins needed to make that sub
amount so I can call my recursive method
pass in that sub amount could pass in
these same old coins in the problem they
tell us that we can reuse a coin as many
times as we need
awesome
but now from here I need to do some
thinking I know that this method call
should give me back a number
representing the minimum number of coins
needed to make the sub amount I'm going
to save that number into a variable here
just readability I'll call it sub coins
because that's the number of coins
needed to make the sub amount and I know
I need to find the minimum subcoins for
every choice of coin that I can take so
I need to perform some Min value logic
here you know generally A Min value
logic means as we iterate over the
possibilities we maintain some outer
variable here I'll call it the mincoins
I have to think about a good default
value for it here well I know that in
the context of the problem they tell us
that all right if it's not possible to
make the amount with the coins then you
want to return negative one so I
actually use that as an initial value
here
so I'm going to set this up as negative
one and I know that after the foil at
the end of my function if I never find a
mount that works I'm going to return
mint coins
which should still be the negative one
right but besides that what if it is
possible to make the sub amount well if
it's possible to make the sub amount
that means that subcoins would be a
non-negative number right so I'm going
to check if
subcoins is not equal to negative one
that means it was possible to make the
sub amount since subcoins is the number
of coins needed to make the sub amount
if I do subcoins plus one that should be
the number of coins needed to make the
full amount and why do I know that this
additional plus one here is counting the
single coin I took to get the sub amount
I'll save it to a variable called int
num coins
so this is the number of coins needed to
make the full amount over here and now I
could compare this against the mincoins
variable right so I'm going to check hey
if this number of coins is less than the
mint coins well then I can replace the
mint coins with this new
number of coins right but it's pretty
obvious here that when we initialize the
mint coins to negative one this negative
one may persist over any valid number of
coins here right because negative one is
already a negative quantity right so
this negative one just acts like a
placeholder right to represent an
invalid quantity or the fact that we
haven't found any valid number of coins
yet and so if the number of coins is
less than Min coins or the Mint coin
still contains that default value then I
can replace that default value with this
number of coins right so I'm performing
A Min value logic over my minimum coins
so this code is looking pretty good one
thing we need to be aware of is when we
calculate this difference here we do a
mount minus coin that could give us a
negative amount right sub amount could
be negative so if we call Min change
with a negative number we already
overshot the Space Case here so what I
can do is just cache that with the base
case so if ever my input amount is less
than zero
then what I want to do is return some
value I'll return negative one here
because again negative 1 in this problem
represents the the fact that the amount
cannot be generated with the coins we're
given right you cannot generate a
negative amount when all of the coins
that you're given are positive
so that's going to be a good extra base
case there
so let's give this a test one this
should be our Brute Force solution for
Min change if all is well we'll add some
memo into it and make it a little faster
so I'm getting an area it looks like I
have a random typo current subcoins that
should just be subcoins plus one right
let's give that a test once again
nice and this looks like our Brute Force
solution we know that an algorithm like
this so far has an exponential run time
just like we said in the approach video
so to speed this up I'm going to use our
memoization strategy
so like I always love to do I'm going to
separate it into a main function and
then a recursive helper right
so my main over here will just call my
recursive helper it's going to take in
the amount as well as the coins but also
my memo which will be a new hash map
I'll be sure to take that hash map as an
argument here
so it's going to be a hash map
and I have to think about what the keys
of this hash map are going to be they
should just be the argument that changes
during the recursion which is the amount
notice that the amount is the only ARG
that changes coins stays the same so I
don't need to add it as a key into my
map here so I'll say my keys are going
to be integer and then the corresponding
values are going to be just the return
type of this method which is also
integer I'll call that memo got to be
sure to import hashmap above
looking pretty good and be sure to pass
along that memo through the entire
recursion now I need to add an
additional base case right I need to
check hey if the memo already contains
the amount well then I've solved this
sub problem before just return the
stored value in the memo so I'll return
memo dot get the amount
awesome but if it's not then I'll go
ahead and actually perform the true
logic and calculate recursively of the
answer
right and I know that now I need to
actually add data into the memo where I
return the result so I look for the
literal return line in my recursive case
and it's only one return statement here
in the recursive case that's line 35. so
literally what I should do is
I ought to save this into my memo so I
can do memo dot put
I'm going to use the input amount as my
key always use the original argument
make the corresponding value mincoins
and you still need to complete the
return value so like before still
logically return mint coins you're just
making sure you store it in the memo
before you leave this recursive call
nice so with that logic built around my
Brute Force by adding the memo we should
get a better run time here
awesome there we have it here we start
to really see the power of this strategy
of first solving a Brute Force recursion
and then applying our memoization trick
right around it really the hardest part
of a situation like this is to solve The
Brute Force recursion in the first place
right but that lets you focus on just
the correct logic and then afterwards
you speed up that logic using this
additional data structure all right
programmers that's all I got for this
one why don't you do is practice this
and I'll see you in the next one hey
programmers I just want to take a little
break from our dynamic programming
material to tell you about structi
Shruti is a complete data structures and
algorithm course that you can use to
prepare for all of your technical
interviews it's actually the course
you've been seeing me use throughout the
video tutorials I'm going to be your
teacher through the entire instructed
curriculum and in the structure course
we cover all of those essential
interview topics like graphs trees
dynamic programming and more and like
you expect for every single problem like
you've seen in this dynamic programming
course we're going to support it with
animations as well as code walkthroughs
and you'll be able to code up all of
these Solutions on the platform tester
code in Java C plus plus JavaScript and
python so if you're enjoying this
dynamic programming material I recommend
you head over to structure where you can
practice things further whether it's
dynamic programming or those other
essential topics and of course you're
going to be joining me for all of those
video walkthroughs so I'll see you there
without any further Ado let's hop back
into our course
hey programmers Alvin here right now
let's go over the approach for this
count paths problem so in this problem
we're going to be given a grid what we
want to do is travel from the top left
corner down to the bottom right corner
and here we want to return the number of
ways that's possible to Traverse through
this grid the caveat is we can only move
to the right or downward that means we
can go up and we can't go to the left
and so for this particular grid let's
talk about the different ways we can
travel through it one way would be to go
right right down another way would be to
go right down right and finally the last
way would be to go down right right and
since there are three possible ways to
travel through this grid we should just
return the number of three so this
should be a counting problem for us
however this problem is a little more
nuanced they say that some positions are
going to be occupied by walls and we
can't travel through them so if I had a
wall like this in the top right corner
then one way to travel to the grid would
be right down right and the only other
way would be downright right so let's
Trace through the strategy for this one
by looking at a larger example if I was
given this 3x3 grid I'll also put a wall
in the top right corner let's start by
labeling the indices for our rows and
columns we know that we start in the top
left corner so that would mean row 0
column zero and what I want to start to
do is try to give myself a way where I
can denote every option I have right how
can I Mark the decisions I can make by
traveling through this grid so I'm going
to visualize this one as a tree
so if I start at position 0 0 I can make
that the root of my tree if I'm at this
position I'll think about my options
that I have I can either move downward
if I move downward that would increase
my row by one but keep my column the
same giving me one comma 0 or if I went
to the right I keep my Row the same at 0
and I increase my column by one and that
would be the only two options I have
from this root position and I can just
apply this logic recursively so let's
say I was situated at the zero one node
right now so I'm over here I know that
my options are more limited now I can't
move to the right because I have a wall
in my way so I'm going to need to make
sure I code that one up and I can only
move downward here and that would mean
increasing my row by one and keeping a
column the same and so let's carry over
this pattern to draw out the rest of
this tree we know that given a node at
most it's going to have two children
representing my downward or rightward
movement and that would mean either
incrementing the row by exactly one or
incrementing the column by one however
we should not do that move if we go out
of bounds or run into a wall so the full
tree would look something like this
what's great about this tree is if I
start at the roots and travel to a leaf
node that would represent one of the
paths I can take through my grid in
other words if I look at this path in my
grid I can represent that using this
path in my tree which is a really nice
way to interpret this problem
and so let's start to realize how we can
encode the base case in this problem
what you should be realizing is we're
visualizing this as a tree which usually
gives us a nice way to implement this as
recursion right so if I've got all the
leaf nodes here I always terminate at 2
comma two because that would represent
the bottom right corner of my grid which
is the goal and so if I'm at the bottom
right position of 2 2 what should I do
here well I have to think about the
return value for my function here right
they say they want a count and so what I
should do is treat this to comma 2
position as if it's its own input so if
someone asks me in how many ways can you
get from the bottom right position to
the bottom right position the answer
would be one right there's only one way
to do that that would be to just stay
there right because you're already at
your goal point and so I'm going to make
all of these Leaf nodes or all these
base cases return one now having these
calls return one seems useful because I
know I need to tally up a count in this
problem
so how do we start reconstructing our
larger Solutions here well I would just
really Bubble Up these ones right
so let's slow down at this one comma one
node over here we know that this node
has a little more work to do because
it's going to receive two values
and so what I should do is bubble up
both of these values right and then this
note should just add them together so
one plus one gives me two and so what
are we saying here if I pause I should
have some logical information in the
subtree what it should be saying is that
there are two ways to get from the
position one comma one to the bottom
right corner I have this path or I have
this path there are two different ways
to get from one one down to your bottom
right corner so I'll just carry over
this pattern keep reconstructing all of
my Solutions
and as we get toward the top of our tree
we are going to get the final count of
all of the ways to travel from the top
left to the bottom right giving us our
final answer of five what's great about
visualizing this one as a tree is it
really describes the decisions we can
make as we travel through the grid right
we know that this gives us a binary tree
because for the most part when we're on
the inside of the grid we only have two
options right you can either move
downward or to the right that'll help us
decide the complexity of this Brute
Force algorithm so if we implement this
algorithm as it is just with some
baseline recursion we say that R is the
number of rows and sees a number of
columns this will give us an exponential
runtime meaning they're an exponential
number of nodes in this tree really it's
2 to the r plus C power so the base of 2
comes from the fact that this is a
binary tree and in the context of a
problem that means I can only move
downward to the right so you only have
two options I'm saying that the height
of this tree is R plus C right because
you know you want to start in the top
left corner 0 0 and travel to the bottom
right corner what you have to do is
actually Traverse a path that is exactly
R plus C moves along right because you
need to move through all of your rows
and all of your columns for the same
reason I can say that the space
complexity is going to be R plus C just
due to the stack depth right stack depth
is equal to the height of this tree
which we just said is roughly R plus C
and so overall we shouldn't be too
satisfied with the time complexity of
this one right typically something
exponential would be too slow for our
liking
and so what we should do is recognize
that we actually have this visualized as
a nice dynamic programming problem
what you should do is take a moment look
at our visual tree and notice if you can
spot any duplicate sub problems right
are there any overlapping sub problems
here that I can memorize
so we actually have a duplicate sub tree
over here rooted in one comma one
what I could do is just save the first
time I calculated that way I don't have
to fully recurse down my tree the second
time around effectively memorizing my
duplicate function calls which in the
context is my tree visual just means
that I prune out some branches there are
some other subtrees here I can look at
this two comma one subtree I can also
memorize that away and we know as we
grow the problem size in other words if
someone gave me a larger and larger grid
I would have more and more overlapping
sub problems so I'd benefit more and
more from memoization like usual for us
the way we'll implement this is by using
some hash map data structure I'll save
that detail for the Code walkthrough
though so what do we know about the new
and improved complexity of this one
right we're going to implement our
dynamic programming using our classic
memoization strategy so like usual R is
the number of rows and C is a number of
columns now would be the case that our
time complexity is R times C right it's
still the case that our time complexity
is driven by the number of recursive
calls we make and now we would be making
roughly R times C different recursive
calls right and how do I know that well
in the context of what I'm going to
memorize into my hatch map I'm going to
put positions right notice that each
node in this visual is a position of row
and column and I know that there are
exactly R times C different rows and
columns so once I store a row and column
into my memo I would never have to fully
recompute it which gives me my time
complexity of R times C likewise now is
the case that my space complexities R
times C taken mostly from the size of
that memo right every position is going
to be a key and so I have R times C
different keys in my memo object all
right programmers I'm sure itching to
see how we actually implement this one
in some code so right now you'll want to
join me in the walkthrough videos I'll
see you there
now that we're done sketching out the
solution behind this count pass problem
what you want to do is head down to the
links in description below where you can
actually access the prompt and the test
cases for this count pass problem and
we'll code up the solution in Java
together
hey programmers Alvin from structure
here what I want to do is go over the
account pass problem in Java so like we
said in the approach video we're going
to frame this problem like a dynamic
programming one this is going to be a
little different compared to our very
classic like graph like grid problems
because in this problem you can only
move rightward or downward that means
that we can't get caught in any Cycles
right so I don't have to do any visited
logic or anything like that
however what I will do is solve this one
with a Brute Force recursion and then
apply our memoization strategy on top of
it to get a really fast dynamic
programming optimized solution so to get
the ball rolling on this one I know I
need to start tracking like a current
position as I Traverse uh through the
grid so I'm going to split this one up
into my main method as well as my helper
and my helper is going to take in my
current row and current column
information and then in my main method
I'll just pass control
to my helper and I'll give it the
starting point which is a top left
corner which means row 0 column zero
pass along the entire grid to reference
then from here I'm going to structure
this one as like a depth first recursive
solution more or less so I'm going to
start with the base case so what's my
goal here well my goal is to find the
bottom right corner of my grid so I can
stop traversing if my row and column is
the bottom right so be careful of the
math here right to be in the bottom of
most row that would mean that the row is
equal to grid dot size
minus one that means the bottom row
similarly you want to check if the
column is equal to the rightmost column
so that would mean grid dot get 0 dot
size minus one right so this is checking
if I'm in the bottom right position then
what do I want to do what I want to
return overall the number of ways to
reach the bottom right corner from this
current position well if you're already
in the Target position then you don't
need to do anything so that's one way
that you can get to the bottom right
corner you just do nothing right because
you're already there so I'll return one
in this instance
we have to think about some other
scenarios right it could be the case
that maybe my row and column is out of
bounds so I want to avoid that and so
I'll check very a very similar condition
here
I'm going to check if I'm out of bounds
that would mean that my row is equal
to grid size or
my column is equal to
grid.get0 dot size right notice that I'm
turning this into an or right because if
your row is too large or your column is
too large well in the theater those are
true or both of those are true then it's
an invalid position so you're out of
bounds right
and if that's the case I still need to
give a logical return value right I
always want to have consistent return
types so even in the space case if I'm
out of bounds I want to return an
integer and an integer needs to
represent how many ways from this
position I can travel to the bottom
right corner well if you're out of
bounds there's no possible way to ever
get to the bottom right corner at that
point so you want to return zero right
there are zero ways to travel from an
out of bounds position to the bottom
right corner
so I have my base cases looking pretty
good but there's one more to capture
here they also tell us that all right
some positions of your grid are not open
o stands for an open position if a grid
position contains an X that's a wall
that I cannot travel through so I'm
going to actually add that into the mix
here right it might be the case
that if
my grid dot get r dot get C so if my
current position is equal to an X well
then I can't Traverse through it right
that's also a dead end kind of I like
out of bounds so I'm similarly going to
return zero awesome do note the
important order of these two cases over
here right I'm making sure that I only
try to access like the innermost element
of my a 2d grid after I check that the
row and column are valid right I know
that I'm using some valid RNC to get a
position of my grid it's just that that
position contains an X
so these are all of my base cases here
now I can start structuring my recursive
case and I know that from any position
that I'm at I have you know two options
to take and those two options will turn
into my two recursive calls right so I'm
going to call account paths you could
move downwards so you could
move down a row keep the column the same
but you can also move to the right so
you can do count Paths of the same row
but increase the column
nice I have to think about what these
two recursive calls return they return a
number right this one on the left
returns to me the number of ways I can
get to the bottom right corner or get to
the goal if I move downward this tells
me the number of ways I can get to the
goal if right now I move to the right if
I take the sum of them that gives me the
total ways I can get to the goal from
this position because from this position
you can only either move down or move to
the right
so this is looking like some core logic
this looks like the shape of my brute
force not much logic to it overall just
some tricky edge cases here for my base
case
and so let me give this a test run
I'm looking for some correct output so
I'm passing some test cases but probably
timing out for large inputs and there we
see it
so like I always love to do now I need
to apply my memoization to it so I'm
going to set that up you always want to
use some fast lookup data structure to
store your memo right
and so for us use something like a
hashmap and I'll pass along that hash
map inline over here so new hash map
and I'll take it as an argument and here
where I design the hash map have to be a
little more particular right so
generally for the keys of my hashmap I
always use the changing arguments into
my recursive method here right so if I
look at the arguments that change during
my recursion it's the row and the column
right the grid itself is always the same
throughout the full recursion so I don't
need to encode it into the keys of my
hash map
and so I really need to represent a row
and column pair or like position as keys
of my hash map because depending on
their own column you get a different
answer
and so to actually store that key I'm
going to use just a list of only two
things of a row and column
so it'll be a list of integer and I'll
just guarantee that I'd make sure that
those sub lists are always going to be
of length two right just pairs of row
and column
and corresponding value is going to be
the return type for my method which is
just integer as well
nice call this memo and now let's add
our memo checking logic so pass these
base cases what I like to do is form the
key I'm going to use into my memo so
create that key here it's going to be a
list of integer let me just a pair I'll
call it my position it's going to be
just a list of the row and column
nice and I can check hey if
this position is in the memo so if memo
dot contains key position and I can
return the associated value with it
because that means I've seen this not
recursive call before so I can just
instantly find the old result so return
memo dot get position again the key
trick here is I'm using this position
because it contains the row and column
arguments right so I'm using that entire
entity as a key into my memo
nice then from there like we're used to
I should be sure to pass the memo to my
calls here
and whenever you see your recursive
return value which is line 30 for me you
want to store that result in your memo
before you leave right
so I'm just going to store this into an
INT result
be sure to put that in your memo so memo
dot put
this is uh put a key of position
with the result
and then just return the result
nice so with those changes pretty
classic changes to the previous problems
that we've been doing except we're
having a little more complex of a memo
key here
let's give that a shot
awesome there's our solution for count
paths
hey programmers Alvin here right now
let's go over the approach for this
maxpath sum problem
so in this problem we're going to be
given a grid and we start in the top
left corner and we want to make our way
to the bottom right corner this grid is
going to be populated with some numbers
though we want to do here is return the
path containing the maximal path sum
in other words there are a few ways we
can travel through this grid one way
would be to use this path in which case
there's sum would be 14. another way
your sum would be 12 and finally you can
use this path in which case your sum
would be 18. and between these three
options I should choose the 18 right and
so that would be the max path sum for
this grid so let's cut to the Chase and
describe the strategy for this one and
we'll step through exactly this example
so we'll label the row and columns and
we also know that we start of course in
the top left corner the SE are really
just a spin-off of our last problem so
hopefully you visualize this one as a
tree right a binary tree because we only
have two options at any point in time
right you can either move downward or to
the right and sometimes in just one of
those directions depending on whether or
not you're at the border of our grid
right so we'll start at zero zero from
this position I have two options if I
went downward I would increase my row by
one notice that each pair within a node
here is a row and column or I could have
moved to the right in which case I would
be at zero comma one now to present my
two moves let's say I was situated at
this one comma zero node here I only
have one move possible to make I must
move to one comma one right that
represents a move to the right if you
look at my row and column indices that's
because I can't go downward anymore
because I'm already in the last row
if I take a look at this position over
here I do have two options right I can
go downward or to the right giving me
one comma one and zero comma two
respectively we can build out the full
tree from this point we know that we
must terminate at position one comma two
because that would be the bottom right
corner so I know that that is our ending
point right so that's going to be my
base case I know in this problem I want
to choose the maximal path sum so I want
to Max some but how can I start
accumulating a sum in the first place
and so what you have to do is ask
yourself if I'm already at the end
position what is its Max path sum to the
end position that would just be the
value of 2 right that's exactly the
number in that ending position so for my
base cases I'm just going to return
whatever number is in that final
position
then from here I know that these values
are going to return so let's say we were
situated at this one comma one node it's
going to receive a value from its child
call because we know we're visualizing
this in a recursive way and what I
should do here is note what position I'm
at so 1 comma 1 would be this position
containing a six I want to accumulate a
sum here so I should do 2 plus 6 giving
me eight so this node is going to return
8 to its parent so it's 8 it's going to
Bubble up a little bit more if I think
about this one comma zero node that
represents my current value of 5 over in
yellow and I would do my 8 plus 5 giving
me 13. so that would be a partial path
so far
so we'll continue this process on our
right hand side we know that these would
just Bubble Up and we would add the
respective values at those positions
things came more interesting when we're
at this zero comma one node though
so for this note it's going to receive
both 8 and 14 right it's just going to
return back up like we always do and I
have to make a decision here since I
want the max path sum this node should
choose the larger of those two values so
14 is bigger than 8. so I prefer the 14
here but I should also still add the
value stored at my current position so
if I look at position 0 1 within my grid
that would be this value of 3. so I add
3 to the 14 giving me 17.
finally this takes place again at the
root so if I'm at 0 0 I'm going to
receive the 13 and the 17 for my
children I choose the bigger value of 17
and then I add my position itself which
has a value of 1 inside that gives me a
final answer of 18. so the way we
reconstructed our sub Solutions into
higher level Solutions was to choose the
larger of our two children and then add
ourselves to it that way I get some max
value logic while also summing our path
we talk about the Brute Force complexity
of this algorithm we say that R is the
number of rows and sees the number of
columns then our time complex is going
to be exponential just like we saw in
the last problem the base of 2 comes
from the fact that given any position we
have two options right we can either go
down or to the right and I make R plus C
the exponent because that would be the
height of this tree right that would be
the length of any particular path I know
any path that travels from the top left
to the bottom right must cover all of
the rows R and all of the columns C and
so the entire path length would be R
plus C in a similar way I'll say the
space complexities R plus C due to the
stack space required by this recursion
right if the height of this tree is R
plus C that means the stack space used
by my recursion is also going to be R
plus C but a keen Observer would know
that I can do better because this is a
dynamic programming problem so what I'll
do is take a moment look at this tree
see if you can find any overlapping sub
problems
and although this example was small I
can already see some overlap if I look
at this node rooted in one comma one I
see it here and you also see it here I
know the punch line is I should only
have to calculate these nodes exactly
once so I should be able to trim out a
little bit of the tree by using some
memoization
and as we actually increase the size of
our input as I get a larger and larger
grid I would have more and more overlap
that I'm able to kind of forego using
some memoization like usual we're going
to implement this using a hash map but
I'll say those finer implementation
details in the walkthrough video
if we Implement memoization properly for
this one we're going to bring our
complexity down to linear right so we're
going to have a Time complexity of R
times C that's because there are R times
C different nodes to actually cover now
right I know I'm going to put the
positions as the keys of my memo and
there are R times C unique positions in
a similar way it's now the case that my
space complexity is taken over by the
size of my memo which is also R times C
because of the number of keys right I
have R times C keys because I have R
times C positions all right I think I'm
ready to code this one up you'll want to
join me in the walkthrough videos now
hey programmers welcome back what I want
to do right now is go over the Java
walkthrough for this Max path sum
problem so it's going to be a small
variation of the previous you know grid
dynamic programming problem except this
time you want to find the maximum as we
travel from the top left of our grid to
the bottom right
so I'm going to start by setting up the
same initial structure so you'll want to
track a position as you kind of Traverse
through your grid
and so I'm going to add additional
arguments to this method so I'm going to
track my current row as well as my
current column
nice and then from there what I want to
do is start laying down my base cases
right
so for my base cases like you expect
there are a few I need to check if I'm
out of bounds so if my row is equal to
grid dot size that means I'm just
outside of the grid
or
maybe my column is equal to grid dot
size
or rather grid dot get zero dot size or
I'm out of the column range right either
case you want to return a sum integer
right how can you represent an invalid
integer meaning it's not possible to
travel to the bottom right corner using
this particular position well because I
want to perform overall like a Max path
logic or max value logic I know my logic
is going to be preferring any larger
integers and so whenever I encounter
like an out of balance or invalid
position I need to return some very
small number right and so for me I think
the best way to solve this one is going
to be to use like a negative Infinity
concept
so in Java really your only choice for
like a true negative Infinity is going
to be in the double type so I'm going to
say double dot negative Infinity which
means I have to adjust some of my types
here right so I guess I'm going to make
this return a double that's totally fine
I'll just be sure to cast it back in my
main method here right so what am I
saying well just so I can have access to
like negative Infinity in my recursive
over here
in my main method it's going to call
maxpath sum with the initial row initial
column as well as the grid and I know
that this is now defined to return a
double you're going to get an error in
Java if you try to return a double from
an integer return method so I'm just
going to cast into
integer I'm just doing that really
straightforward so I'm only going to
convert at the very end which is fine
all right so beyond that I need to just
handle the case where I actually hit my
Target in a base case so that'll be a
similar condition right you want to
check in English if you're in the bottom
right position
so if your row is the last row
and
your column is the last column
and so you want to return
some number here and overall you want to
be adding up the values in your grid as
you travel along them so in your base
case you want to return an actual value
you want to return the value of your
current position so you want to return
grid.get
r
dot get C so what am I really saying
here so let's say that we're performing
our recursion and we hit this base case
meaning we're at the bottom right corner
so that means I'm at this position what
I'm going to do here is return the value
at this position so I'm returning the
value of one I'm going to return it
because I need to eventually add up all
the values along my winning path and the
end goal is still part of my winning
path here
nice and so now that I have these base
cases in line what I want to do is start
forming my recursive case so I know I'm
going to have two recursive calls right
because at any position I have two
options I can either go down or go to
the right so I'm going to call maxpath
sum going downward would be R plus 1 C
grid and going to the right would be
maxpath sum of the same row increase the
column same old grid
nice and here what I want to do is
prefer the larger sub answer right
because when I take a path through my
grid you either go right or you go down
right and I know that these recursive
calls can be back a number they
represent the sum of the a path if I
travel through the right or if I travel
downward and I want to choose whichever
sub result is bigger right because right
might give you a bigger sum or going
down might be a bigger Sum It could only
take one of them
and so to choose just the maximal
between these two numbers that I get
back I'm just going to use the built-in
math.max you can also write some
conditional logic this is probably the
easiest way to write this though
so just choose the bigger value between
these two methods but I should also be
sure to add my current position into uh
that answer right so I'm going to do
grid dot get our
dot get C
add it into the bigger between my going
down choice or my going rightward choice
right this gives me the logic of summing
up all the values along a particular
path awesome so let's give this code a
run this should be our Brute Force
solution it looks like
nice and if all is well we should start
timing out and there we have it
so let's improve the runtime of this one
by adding in our memo so that's going to
be a hashmap
this is going to have us use a hash map
where the keys are going to be positions
right because the row and column is what
determines the answer here because those
are the arguments that change
so I should have passed along a new hash
map here
and over here I'll Define the type so
hash map
keys are going to be positions so just
kind of list pairs to integers
corresponding value is going to be looks
like double
I'll call that memo
so like we always do we want to add our
memo checking logic as an additional
base case so I'll start by forming the
key first
which is really just a position pair
list of the row and column
and then start by checking if it's in
the memo so if memo
contains
the key of position then return its
corresponding stored value so I'll
return memo
dot get position
nice and then beyond that I need to be
sure to pass along this memo so it's
shared through the entire recursion so
just pass it by reference here not a big
deal and like I always say right the key
is to now just find your recursive
return value which is this thing over
here you want to store it in your memo
before you return right so this long
expression just is a double it's like
just a sum right so I'll save that as a
result
and this is going to be
double
how do I know it's double well it's
obviously double because of this over
here what I want to do is store it in my
memo so memo dot put use your original
arguments the original key
here
make the corresponding value the result
and then like before still return the
same old result the only additional step
you took was to store it for a rainy day
because I know later on if I ever
encounter this position again I would
hit this conditional and I can return
that sub result in constant time
which gives me a much better performance
here
give that a test run
added our dynamic programming strategy
there we have our very Snappy code
hey programmers Alvin here right now
let's go over the approach for this
non-adjacent sum problem
from this problem you're going to do is
take in an array containing some numbers
what you want to do is return the
maximal sum of non-adjacent elements in
this array so that means we can never
take two numbers that are next to each
other within the array for this
particular input the answer should be 16
because the max non-adjacent sum would
contain the 4 plus 12.
here we should notice that we can't take
a sum like 12 plus 7 because those two
elements are adjacent within the array
let's take a look at another example
let's say I was given 7 5 5 and 12. in
this particular scenario the output
should be 19 representing the sum of 7
and 12 which is totally fine because
they are non-adjacent in the array
so let's come up with the strategy for
this one we'll step through the example
of 2 4 5 12 and 7. what I want to do is
figure out a way I can come up with all
the possibilities for numbers I take
into my sum and numbers I exclude from
my sum because we know that based on the
numbers we take that would actually
limit our options later on so let's say
we started to encode this as a recursion
tree right so I'm going to describe all
the decisions that we could take as we
come up with a sum for this problem
so I'm going to start with my original
array at the root what I have to do is
come up with a decision right now let's
say I was making a decision for the
first element of this array so if I took
2 into my sum then I know my resulting
elements I can choose from is really
just 5 12 and 7. so notice how I did
this left Branch over here right I'm
writing 2 along the edge to represent
that I'm taking 2 into the sum and
notice how I make my array smaller in
that left child I just have 5 12 and 7
because I cannot include 4 in that next
call right because including four would
actually mean that we're giving
ourselves the opportunity to take an
adjacent sum right if you take two right
now then you can never ever take four so
that's why I exclude it however at the
root we could have also just not taken
two altogether in which case when you
look at your next subarray that would
just be 4 5 12 and 7 right if I don't
take the two that means I'm excluding it
along the edge on the right hand side
then I can totally give myself the
opportunity to take four in the future
so I'm going to include it in the next
array so let's carry this pattern
further let's say we looked at this left
note over here what I have to do is
always make a decision about the first
element of this array so for the five
note if I decide to take it what I can
do is then look at the remaining
elements of just seven right I don't
pass 12 until the remaining subarray
because if I take 5 I cannot take 12.
however I could have also just not taken
5 altogether which case my remaining
elements are just 12 and 7. so by now it
should be clear how we generalize the
steps here right given any particular
array what I can do is either take the
first element or not take the first
element and that would decide what
remaining elements I can choose from
either slicing off one or two elements
from the front of my array
let's say we evaluated this node over
here if I take 4 then I would give me a
remainder of 12 and 7. if I don't take 4
then my remainder is 5 12 and 7.
something interesting happens at the
seven node right so in one scenario I
can take the seven in which case I
really just have an empty array left
over right there's nothing else to
choose for because that's my last
element and the scenario that I don't
take seven you would still have an empty
array left over so notice how the seven
node terminates and really two empty
arrays finally we'll evaluate this 12
comma 7 node if I took the 12 then I
would have an empty array because if I
take the 12 you cannot take the 7
anymore and if I don't take the 12 well
then I can totally take the 7 for my
next decision
at this point we would actually have a
larger tree right there are still some
nodes I need to evaluate here fully but
what's great about this is I can
actually notice that those are all
duplicate nodes in other words I've
noticed that this is a dynamic
programming problem right if something
has dynamic programming present in it
then I should be able to recognize any
overlapping sub problems in the context
of this tree I just have to notice any
duplicate nodes any duplicate subtrees I
can notice a duplicate sub tree rooted
in seven right so I don't need to
re-explore the seven node again likewise
I can notice a duplicate subtributed in
12 comma 7. there's even more than that
I even have a very large subtree rooted
in 5 12 and 7. and so I'm going to save
a lot of complexity by saving some of
these sub Solutions as I compute them
so let's talk about how you can
recompute our final answer from the
problem now that we broke it down
what we should notice is toward the
bottom of our tree we're going to have
leaves that represent empty arrays which
does feel good because we know as our
problem size gets smaller and smaller
that would mean a smaller and smaller
array right less and less numbers to
choose from
let's make our base case about the empty
array in other words if someone gave me
an empty array then the max non-adjacent
sum would be zero right just take no
elements of the array because you don't
really have an option here so for all of
these empty nodes or the empty arrays
I'm going to have them return zero I
know I'm going to make that a base case
let's say we wanted to evaluate now at
the seven node how will it use those sub
Solutions well if I take a look at the
left return value that's going to Bubble
up but what I should also do is add the
7 along the edge right the yellow seven
that represents the fact that I was
taking and including 7 into that sum so
I have a 7 on my left and for the right
hand child that just bubbles up as it is
right because I did not include seven
for that particular sub problem and at
this point I have this node choosing
between seven and zero since I want the
max non-adjacent sum I choose the larger
between the two so I should return 7 in
this instance
so now let's evaluate this 12 comma 7
node since I just evaluated the seven
node into its result I'm just going to
jot down that answer here and I know I
would Implement that probably using some
memorization
but as I carry on my return values here
the left-hand0 is going to Bubble Up but
I add the value along the edge because I
was including 12 to that sum so I have
12 on my left and 7 on my right I choose
a large between the two and I should
return 12. which makes sense because if
you think about it given just the small
sub array of 12 comma 7 the Max on
adjacent sum would be 12 right just
choose 12. definitely don't choose 7
because that'd be smaller
now that I've evaluated this 12 comma 7
node I know I can save this result for
later on so I'm going to jot it down on
that duplicate node over here
now let's evaluate a little higher up
we'll carry over the same logic as
before so I return these values and I
add the 5 along the left hand Edge
giving me 12. at this point I choose the
larger between 12 and 12. it's really a
tie here so I'll just return 12. so I've
just computed the subsolution for the
array 5127 and I actually have a
duplicate node on the right hand side so
I'm going to jot that down
if I evaluate this node now things
Bubble Up along the left hand Edge I add
a 4 giving me 16. so I do 16 versus 12.
I choose a larger one which of course be
16. finally at the ultimate root I
return these two values but the left
hand Edge gets a plus two I choose a
larger between 14 and 16 giving me my
final answer of 16 which would be the
correct answer let's talk about the
complexity for this one so if you say
that n is the length of the numbers what
we could do is analyze the Brute Force
complexity of this right so if you did
not optimize this by trimming out some
duplicate nodes in your sub tree you
would have an exponential runtime in
other words your time complexity is 2 to
the n and your space complexity is just
o of n we can say that the time
complexity is 2 to the N here because
for every node of this tree it's going
to give at most two children right so in
the worst case from one level of the
tree to the next I double the number of
nodes and I also know that the height of
this tree is going to be n right the
height of the tree is going to be n
because in some scenario I could just
keep removing the first elements of my
array again and again and that means
that the deepest recursion would require
n stack frames on the call stack like we
said we can optimize this with some
dynamic programming with some
memoization if you did things correctly
here you would get a runtime of just o
event so linear and a space complexity
of also o of n one thing to note for
this one is if you really want to get
the linear runtime out of this problem
you're going to have to figure out a
clever way to actually represent a
logical shrinkage of your array in other
words if you look at the nodes of my
tree I'm representing the array and I'm
chopping off some elements of the array
at any point in time what you don't want
to do is create many copies of the array
because I know creating a copy of an
array would itself run in a linear time
if you're creating a copy within every
recursive call it's going to be pretty
inefficient I will actually save that
detail for the implementation video and
so if you're wondering how to exactly
Implement that pattern you'll want to
join me in the walkthrough video I think
let's hop to it
hey programmers Alvin here what I want
to do right now is go over the Java
solution for this non-adjacent sum
problem so like we said in the approach
video to solve this one we're going to
solve it using some recursive Brute
Force algorithm then apply some
amylization on top of it
and so to get the ball rolling here I'm
gonna need a way to give myself the
ability to look at different pieces of
my input list here I know at any point
in time I want to shrink my input list
smaller and smaller toward my base case
and so to set up that structure I think
it's good to have access to like a
starting index so I'm going to overload
the method name here
I'm going to give it another argument
I'll say int I
and this will represent the starting
index of the sub list that I'm
considering for example if I is the
number two that means I should be
analyzing the list starting at index two
so index two all the way through the end
that means top level over here when I
call my helper method I'll call nine
adjacent sum given the same nums list
and then initialize I to be zero because
you want to start considering the full
list starting index 0 going through the
end
this will help us avoid any slicing or
creating copies of the list as we go
giving us a faster solution
and so to get the ball rolling on our
Brute Force let's consider some base
cases here
and so I know I want to check a base
case if my list that I'm considering is
empty right
so I'm gonna check
for me a logical like empty linked list
would mean that my index I is at the end
or past the end of the list here so I'll
check if I is greater than or equal to
num's dot size
notice that here I'm technically
checking if I is out of bounds of the
nums list because I know the last valid
index of a list would be size minus one
so if that's the case what I want to do
is return 0. for what I'm trying to be
consistent with the return type of this
method which would be of type integer
and zero is definitely an integer and
I'm returning 0 because it represents an
empty sum because I know overall in the
context of this problem I want to
maximize the sum that I take
and so with that let me also start
forming my recursive calls and these
recursive calls should really mimic the
logic that we express when we drew the
approach video tree right
so we have really two options here I'll
kind of lay them out
well what you could do is take the
number at the front of your list so for
me the front of my logical list would be
the item at index I
so if you took that number you could say
nums.get I
and you want to recursively add it to
the sum of the remaining part of the
list that you can take from if you take
the element at position I
and when you call non-jacent sum
they'll give him the same nums list but
you want to manipulate I obviously I
want to increase I giving myself like a
smaller a logical list
what you want to do is pass in I plus 2
here
and so it's pretty clear why we're not
just passing in the same old I well for
one we already took the element that
index I into our sum and we're adding it
to our recursive sum here
we shouldn't pass in I plus 1 because
that would be a number adjacent to I
right and if we take I right now we know
we can't take I plus 1 later on because
the whole point of this problem is you
can't take two elements that are
adjacent in the list
and so the earliest number we could take
from there would be I Plus 2. and this
is a very indicative of the logic we
expressed when we drew the tree
so that's only half of the pattern here
could also be a scenario where I don't
take my current element at index I and
instead I just do non-adjacent sum of
nums
and then I pass in I plus 1 here right
so now I do have the option of taking
the element that's right after I
nice and I know that these two variables
over here are these two expressions they
give me back a number right they
represent a sum
what I want to do is now work in my max
value logic I want to choose the maximum
answer between these two choices right
the choices you make are either you take
your element index I or you don't take
your element in x i so I'm going to
choose the maximum between them for me I
could just use the built-in math.max
just takes into arguments and Returns
the bigger value between them and now
that I'm choosing the maximum between
these two quantities you just want to
return whatever that maximum is
so this code's looking pretty good let's
give this a test run so far
really short logic
but we do want to optimize this in a
moment so we're passing our initial test
cases and we're timing out test case
zero four so we're in good shape here we
know that you know the problem like this
does have an exponential runtime so it's
too slow to run but I can add some
memosization logic into the mix here to
improve that
so like we're always used to should know
this formula by now I'm going to bring
in the hash map
I'm going to pass it into my recursive
method here
when it comes to the structure of this
hashmap
its keys are always going to be like the
changing arguments to my recursor method
so I'll pass in a hash map here
for me the keys need to represent my
integer's I right so I'll make the key
type integer
corresponding value is going to be the
return type of the method which is also
integer so this hashmap Maps integers to
integers
and let me add my base case to check if
a key already exists in the memo and for
me the key is really the argument I
right so if the memo
contains the key of I then just return
the stored value because I would have
stored the subsolution previously so
return memo dot get I
now on the flip side I have to locate my
recursive return value which is this
expression over here and I want to store
it in the memo before I leave right so
I'll just save this thing to a variable
I'll call it result
I'm still going to complete the return
value that way we don't change any of
the actual arithmetic in this evaluation
but I do want to save this result so
before I leave I'm going to do
memo dot put use your argument I the
plain old I as their key make the
corresponding value
the result
and always be sure to pass along that
memo by reference into your recursive
method here
does that mean right here
pass along the memo so I have that
shared data structure
and so just by adding this layer on top
of our Brute Force let's give that a
test run
we should get a much better run time
here
cool and there we have it
hey programmers Allen here right now
let's go over the approach for the
summing squares problem so the first
thing we'll want to do is review what a
perfect square is you can create a
perfect square by just taking some
positive number and multiplying it by
itself in other words I can do one times
one to give me one two times two to give
me four three by three to give me 9 and
4x4 to give me 16 and so on
so in this problem we're going to take
in a number as input and we want to do
is figure out the minimum perfect
squares that sum up to our Target number
so for this input of 12 the least number
of perfect squares I can use would be
doing four plus four plus four notice
that this is a valid perfect square sum
because 4 is of course a perfect square
another way that uses perfect squares to
add up to 12 would be nine plus one plus
one plus one however that would be a
longer way right I want to use the
minimum number of perfect squares and so
here I should return the answer of three
and the reason behind it is because I do
4 plus 4 plus 4 which is three perfect
squares all right so how can we break
down this problem let's step through the
example as if our input was 10. we're
going to start at 10 at my root and what
I know I have to do is get this number
to be smaller and smaller because
decreasing the size of our input would
mean an easier and easier problem to
solve so what I have to do is subtract
different perfect squares from this 10.
so what I can do is subtract one that'll
give me 9 or I could subtract 4 giving
me six and finally I could subtract 9
giving me one notice that there are no
other perfect squares to try the next
perfect square would be 16 but that
would be too large for my 10. so I don't
need to go over it over here let's say I
now wanted to expand this nine node I
would get children like this again
branching for every perfect square that
I can take out of that quantity
and so on and so forth
if we look at the right hand side of my
tree I actually just discovered a way to
create my input of 10. in other words I
can look at this path since this path
terminates in a zero that must mean that
we have just found a way to sum up
perfect squares such that we get 10. if
I look at the numbers along this path
I'm really saying nine plus one
so let's expand this five node as well
as this two node and we'll build the
full tree for the subtree rooted in six
that would look something like this
so you can probably foresee that this
tree grows very quickly and so we're
going to avoid drawing the left hand
side of the tree although now we know
the core pattern that we can use to
generate it so if I look at this sub
tray I have a few different paths that
terminate at zero right I can look at
this path which represents another way I
can create my input of 10 but I should
obviously prefer a shorter path right if
I count the number of edges within a
path that would tell me the number of
perfect scores I use to accumulate that
sum and obviously the shortest path we
should return here is two because we're
using a nine and a one let's go through
how we can actually code this one up so
as always if I have this visualized as a
tree I should be able to frame it as
some recursion so in my base case if my
number my input is zero then what I
should do is return zero zero is a great
return value because what we're saying
is to create zero you need to sum up
zero different perfect squares so I'm
going to plug in that return value for
all these Leaf nodes and as I return
these values to their parents what I
have to do is add one to them always
that way I can start counting the number
of edges so if I look at the very bottom
right now the zero returns then I add
one to it then it returns upward add one
to it and one more time to get over here
notice that I have a three over the
three now which means that I need three
perfect squares to create three which
makes sense because you have to do one
plus one plus one let's say we return at
this four node since this node is
receiving two different values what it
should do is choose these smaller
between the two right because this
problem is asking us for the least
number of perfect squares so I need to
minimize here so I should prefer the
zero what I should also do is add one to
it to count the edge
and so what I'm saying right now is
there must be only one perfect square
that I need to get a quantity of four
which makes sense because 4 itself is a
perfect square so I should be able to
notice any correctness even as I
evaluate these sub trees
so we'll take some time to evaluate this
further
until finally at the sixth node we get a
result of three and this three
represents a few different paths we can
take that are of minimal length
so I think by now you understand the
logic we need to evaluate this tree this
tree is going to be a little large so I
won't step through the full example we
can already foresee the complexity of
this though right whenever I have a tree
structure like this I'm describing all
the different recursive calls that I
make so if I'm able to figure out the
number of nodes in this tree that would
tell me the time complexity that stems
from the recursion what I know is the
height of this tree is definitely going
to be n right because the longest path
from the root to a zero would be just by
taking a minus one again and again right
so the height of this tree is going to
be n when it comes to the branching
factor it's actually Dynamic so given a
node we know that we Branch for every
perfect square that we can fit inside of
it we know that given a node n there
would be square root of n different
perfect squares so that'll tell us our
total complexity
we'll say that the time complexity is
going to be the square root of n raised
to the nth power
like usual the branching factor of our
tree is going to be the base of that
exponent in this problem the base is no
longer two right we were dealing with a
lot of problems we just have a base of
2. now we have a branching Factor that's
based on the square root of that number
so that's why we say we have square root
of n raised to the nth power the
exponent of n of course represents the
number of levels in this tree or the
height of the tree
in a similar way the spacing Plex is
just linear o of n because of the height
of our tree we know that we're going to
need at most n stack frames in our
deepest call stack
and like you could probably guess this
is actually going to be framed as a
dynamic programming problem right what
we can do is notice some overlapping sub
problems looking at our tree you can
capture a few I'll just point out this
duplicate 5 node and of course as we
grew our input larger and larger you
would have more and more overlap
so if you do things properly here and
you implement memoization to capture the
dynamic programming nature of this
problem which you should be able to do
is bring it to some sort of a
multi-linear function overall your time
complexity would be n times the square
root of n interspacing Plexi would still
be o of n I'm sure wondering exactly how
we implement this one so maybe what you
want to do is try to code it up on your
own if you get stuck you can find me in
the Code walkthrough I'll see you there
hey programmers after construct be here
what I want to do is go over the Java
walkthrough for the summing squares
problem so you definitely want to make
sure you watch the approach video first
and we'll Jump Right In Here we want to
solve this one using a Brute Force
recursion and apply some memoization on
top of it
so let's start with a base case here
like we said in the approach video we
know we want to deal with an input
that's very small right for us we have
integer inputs so we'll just check if
our number n is equal to zero
if our number n is equal to zero then we
want to return zero because we know that
generally our method should give us back
the number representing the minimum the
number of squares used to build up our n
right if your n is zero that means you
can use the empty sum right you can add
up no perfect squares and you still get
the correct answer of zero so that's the
logic behind our base case here but now
the recursive case is much trickier we
know we want to have the logic of
subtracting out some perfect squares
from n that gives us a smaller and
smaller argument
so I'm going to give myself a loop that
just iterates over some possible squares
so what I can do here is I can iterate
for it's I equals one and I'm starting
at 1 because I know that one is the
smallest perfect square right so I might
as well start there
I'm going to iterate
up to I less than or equal to the square
root
of n
and then hit every I in between I plus
equals one
cool that's because as I evaluate this
Loop what I'm going to do is take my
integer I
am going to create a square number out
of it a square is just the number
multiplied by itself
notice that on the last iteration of
this for loop I know that I is going to
be exactly the square root of n so when
I do I times I I'm definitely going to
get the full value of N and this could
be the biggest number we ever subtract
out of our argument n here
nice and so with that out of the way we
want to do is now build our recursive
call so I'm going to call summing
squares
and I'm going to do n minus this choice
of square that I have over here we know
that this recursive call is going to
give us back the minimum number of
squares required to sum up to this
quantity right
I'll call that my int num squares
however if I wanted to figure out the
number of squares to build up for our
argument n we need to add 1 to that sub
quantity right that's because this one
over here corresponds to the single
Square I have on line 9. nice and then I
know I need to find the minimal
sum and so what I want to do is some Min
value logic here so I'm going to do int
I'll say Min squares
and here it would be nice if I can use
some like Infinity value because I want
to do Min value logic overall and so
unfortunately like integer type doesn't
have a built-in infinity and so what
I'll do is I'll actually create this as
my recursive helper
and so the main method will have the
original
signature
but my recursive method I'll think I'll
make it
actually return double
because then I can start defaulting
these values over here right so for line
I can make this default to double dot
positive Infinity
and I get some safe comparison over here
right so I can say things like hey if
this number of squares is less than the
Min squares and on the first iteration
this is guaranteed to be true because
Min square roots is positive Infinity
then you can go ahead and replace them
in squares with that value
then after that full loop is done
running like you expect we return
whatever Min squares is and since we're
storing positive Infinity in this
variable over here this should be of
course type double
which means that now we're summing
squares recursive method is returning a
double which is totally fine
however when we actually call this
helper method in our main method here
we know that this call to summing
squares
that's actually going to give us a
double I want to just cast it into an
INT like so
I'll pass along the same end here
do bear in mind that right now because
these methods of summing squares
although I want to overload them they
will probably get a conflict here
because they both take in the same types
of arguments and the return type is kind
of ambiguous here so just for now I'm
going to rename the helper method
I'll call it underscore or something
Square so that represents my recursive
helper method
nice and so with that let's give this a
run
here I'm just getting a little reference
here for the typing this should be
positive in fin it t
and while I'm here I also noticed that
when I add one to the results of the
recursive method here that of course
gives me back a double
and that's because the method returns a
double I'm adding one to it which should
still give a double
let's give that a test run
nice and this looks like our Brute Force
recursion is starting to time out though
on test case zero six
so you know the drill at this point we
have our Brute Force let's add our
memosization into it
so I'm going to start by importing the
hashmap
and I'll pass it along to my cursor
method here so it'll be a new hash map
I'll take in this argument here
so hashmap keys are going to be just the
numbers n so integer corresponding value
right now is going to be double
I'll call that my memo
and we'll add a base case like we always
do if our argument n is in the memo so
if memo dot contains a key of n then
return
ammo.get and right return the stored
value for it then I need to locate where
I call My Method recursively which is
over here be sure to share the memo
and then whenever you do your return
value in the recursion you want to store
that result before you leave right so
here I return Min squares I'll want to
save that in a variable I'll say result
equals mint squares
I'm going to still return that same old
result but before I leave I store it in
memo so memo dot put use the original
argument as the key right so I just use
n here
make resolve the value
nice and so now that the overloaded
version of this method has a different
argument of hashmap it should be
unambiguous now so I'm going to actually
change the name here
it's just a summing squares right it's
easily to identify now because there's
two arguments for the recursive version
right only one argument for the main
version here
so let's give that a test run
always solving these dynamic programming
problems and layers
great there we have it
hey programmers Alvin here right now
let's go over the approach for this
counting change problem so this problem
we're going to be given two arguments
we're going to be given a Target amount
as well as an array filled with some
coin values what we want to do in this
problem is return the number of ways
that's possible to make the amount given
the coins in the array and we can reuse
the coin value as many times as we want
and so for this particular example let's
go through the ways we can make an
amount of four one way would be to use
just a bunch of one cent coins or you
could do a three plus a one you can also
do a two plus a two and finally you can
use one two cent coin and then two one
cent coins
and so that means there are four
distinct ways to generate our amount
so let's Trace through an algorithm you
can use to solve this one we'll start by
structuring the different decisions we
can make when it comes to building our
amounts of four so I'm going to use four
at the root and like we're used to let's
go ahead and Branch for every coin value
that we have available in other words
what I could do is take a one cent coin
in which case I reduce my target amount
from four to three or I could take a two
cent coin in which case I have two cents
remaining or I could take a three cent
coin in which case I have one cent
remaining you've seen this pattern a few
times in the course already if we built
out the full tree we'd end up with a
structure like this notice that we
terminate wherever we have zero because
that must mean we actually successfully
built our Target amounts we know that a
zero Leaf would represent one of the
ways to create our mount looks like we
have too many zeros here you're going to
see that we have seven zeros but we said
that there are only four ways to create
our Target amount let's start by
interpreting one of these paths so let's
say I looked at this path this path will
represent me taking coins one plus two
plus one and if I look at another path
like this one in pink this is represent
the way of taking two plus one plus one
if we look at those two paths they
actually represent the same coins right
I'm using a single two cent coin and
then two one cent coins I just took them
in a different order and that's why we
have a high count right now we're
actually counting duplicate ways and so
I don't want to return seven although my
tree says that I should really return
four so actually structuring our tree
like this is not going to be the way to
solve this problem so what would be a
better way well we can still use our
tree structure so we're going to break
this one down recursively but we want to
build it in a way where we don't have
any duplicate paths right and so what
we'll do is starting at the root of our
tree we're going to make a decision for
just a single type of coin so at this
top level of my tree I'm only writing a
decision for my one cent coins and so
for this coin with a value of one what
I'm deciding on is how much of this coin
to take so I could take zero one cent
coins in which case my quantity that I'm
targeting my target amount still stays
at four
or I could take a single one cent coin
in which case my amount is now three if
I take two one cent coins then now my
amount is two and this would just carry
further until I've exhausted all the
possibilities for my differing
quantities of one cent coins so notice
here along the edges of my tree now I'm
denoting the quantity of the coin I'm
taking and at this first level I'm
taking coin one what I can notice
immediately is I already have a node
that terminates at zero so this must
mean that represents one way I can
generate my amounts of four and what
this path represents is really me taking
four one cent coins and on the next
level of the tree I'll wanna do is make
the same decisions but for our two cent
coins so let's say I wanted to expand
this note of four what I do is Branch
for different quantities for my coin
value too so I can take zero two cent
coins one two cent coins or two two cent
coins and that would give me four two
and zero as my reigning amount
respectively so we're gonna need some
more room here our tree's getting a
little wide what I can do is notice this
amount of one since I'm trying to decide
how many two cent coins to take I
actually can't take any two cent coins
out of that amount so this darkened node
basically is going to be a dead end so
we can effectively ignore it that's
going to be true throughout this tree
whenever we have an amount that we can
no longer shrink we actually don't need
to expand that node anymore
and so let's reorganize things over here
now let's expand this node of three and
again I'm branching for different
quantities of two cent coins right so I
can take a zero two cent coin or I can
take just one two cent coin which case I
result in amount of three and are
amounts of one I'll carry this further
for the other nodes at this level
notice at this point we've just
encountered more zero amounts which
means they represent other ways to
create our Target so so far we've
counted three distinct ways to create
our initial Target amounts of four
finally at the bottom level we choose
different quantities for our coin value
of three
notice that some of the leaves here
don't terminate in a zero which means
that they don't represent valid ways to
make my initial amount what I can notice
at the bottom level though is I have an
additional zero this would actually give
me all of the four different ways I can
create my target amount
so the key pattern here is we want to
make sure that up front we choose
different quantities for a single coin
value before moving to the next coin
value altogether what I don't want to do
is flip back and forth between different
coin values because then I would end up
looking at duplicate ways if you think
about how we have the tree structured
now we have a very short tree right this
tree's height is just going to be the
length of the coins array because at
every level of this tree I'm choosing
for a different coin value so although
my tree is very short I actually have
now a very wide tree because now I'm
iterating through differing quantities
it's like you can probably foresee we
can totally structure this problem like
a dynamic programming problem meaning
you could spot duplicate subtrees here
let's take into account the shape of our
tree to come up with the complexity of
this so if we implement this wisely with
some dynamic programming via some
memoization we should end up with a time
complexity that's a multi-linear so just
a times c and a space complexity that's
also a times C we say that the time
complexity is a times C because is a is
the width of the tree and c is now the
height of the tree and in general the
number of nodes would be the height
times the width the space complexity is
also going to be a times C because of
the different keys we're going to need
to put inside of our memo hash map
you're probably wondering exactly how we
implement this and why the complexity is
the way it is and to do that we're going
to actually have to implement the code
together so at this point you'll want to
join me in the walkthrough videos I'll
see you there
hey programmers welcome back what I want
to do right now is go over the Java
walkthrough for this counting change
problem
so in this problem like we said it's
going to be a variation of our you know
coin changing problems and what we want
to do is this time return a number of
ways that we could generate our Target
amounts like we said in the approach
video the thing to watch out for here is
to make sure that you don't count any
duplicate ways and so the structure of
this recurs is going to be a little bit
different I'm going to need an
additional argument into my recursive
method here and so I'm going to Define
it down below it's going to have mostly
the same signature I'm still going to
take in the amount as well as all the
option of coins I'm also going to take
in an index I'll call it coin index
this is going to represent the index of
the current coin I'm going to consider
which means top level over here when I
call my recursive method I'm going to
give in the same old Target amount I'm
going to give it an initial coin index
of zero and of course pass along the
original choice of coins here
and so what I get to do now with this
coin index is now vary the quantity that
I'm going to take the coin of the given
index like we said the approach video we
want to count the number of ways to
generate the amount
so recursively I want to be reducing
this amount over time toward my base
case in other words once my target
amount is zero I have to think about how
many different ways can I give back zero
cents and the answer there is one right
there's exactly one way you can give
back zero cents and that way is to do
nothing right so this one represents me
counting a valid way right there's one
way to make zero sense
good and then from there what I want to
do is now iterate over the possibilities
so I know that given this coin index if
I use it to access some value out of the
coins list I can do coins.get coin index
and I'm going to create a variable to
store it I'll call it int value so this
is the value of the current coin I'm
considering so if I take a look at the
first example in the event that coin
index is zero that means my value is one
it's like a one cent coin in the case
that my coin index is one that means the
value I get is two
what I want to do is take varying
amounts of this coin value
so I'm going to start iterating here and
this Loop is going to be
different from our previous coin prompts
in that we want to iterate over a
different quantity right so I'm going to
say int quantity if I think about what
the lowest quantity of a coin I can take
is well the answer there is zero you
could take no instances of a coin
and I know I'm going to increase that
quantity over time to go through the
possibilities but I have to think about
how far I need to go what I want to do
is iterate this Loop while the quantity
times value is less than or equal to the
Target amount so here I'm checking that
my quantity times value is less than or
equal to the amount because I don't want
to overshoot my amount so for example
let's say that right now my coin index
is 1 right so that means I'm looking at
the element of 2 over here right if I do
my quantity times the value I have to
think about what's the most number of
two cent coins I can take right now if
my target amount is four right well in
the first iteration this is going to be
valid because I'm going to check if 0
times 2 is less than or equal to 4 right
and that's true so I keep running the
iterations I'm going to check if 1 times
2 is less than or equal to 4. that's
still true then I check if 2 times 2 is
less than or equal to 4 and that's still
true but on the next iteration when my
quantity is 3 I'm going to do my 3 times
2 which is 6 and that's no longer less
than or equal to my target amount of
four because I don't want to take out
six cents for my target of 4 cents
that'll give me a negative quantity
right so this condition ensures that I
only iterate up to a valid point here
so what I want to do now is generate my
sub amount so I can do my int sub amount
and I'll make that equal to the original
amount but just minus the quantity
times the value right I'm reducing the
amount by the number of coins that I'm
taking then from there I have this
reduced quantity I want to call
recursively on Counting chain now given
that sub amounts
and because I just made a choice for how
many instances of this coin index I'm
going to take what I want to do is now
move to the next coin so here's where I
increment my coin index
so coin in X plus one right notice that
this for Loop is going to iterate
through all the possibilities for my
given coin index and once I make a
choice of that coin index I can never go
back to it and so that's why I increment
my coin index in the next recursive call
along with that I can pass along these
same coins right that doesn't change
awesome now I have to think about the
logic of my my problem here I know that
in the approach video I wanted to have
the effect of taking a total right I
wanted to add up the sum of all of the
branches through my tree so I know that
counting change is going to return an
integer that integer represents all of
the ways that I can generate these sub
amount
so what I want to do is take the grand
total of that so I'll say int
total ways equals zero and I'm going to
add
the results over here
nice so I'm getting the grand total
number of ways and after my for loop I
just want to turn the total ways
just a little type over here I should be
saying total ways so this looks mostly
good except I should consider also
adding a base case regarding my coin
index in other words what if it's the
case that you actually exhaust all of
your different options for your coin
index but your amount is still not zero
so let's say after this if statement if
I get past this if statement I know my
amount is not zero right I also want to
check hey if my coin index has no other
options in it in other words if my coin
index is greater than or equal to coins
dot size then I have no more options
right I know the last valid index of
coins is coins.size minus one so if coin
index is equal to coins that size I know
I don't have any more coins I can
possibly take so if you hit this case
you want to return zero right there's no
possible ways to generate your amount
from this point because you already
chose all of your quantities for your
different coin indices
nice the order of these conditions is
really important right because I have
this if statement of line 13 after line
9 this is technically checking all right
if my amount is not zero and my coin
index is out of bounds right and I'm
able to accomplish that logically by the
order of these two conditionals
so what the let's give this a test run
this could be our initial Brute Force
solution
looks like we're going to timeout
nice because we get that not so great
exponential runtime here
so like where you see we'll go ahead and
memorize this right
so I'm going to bring in my hashmap
and I'll be sure to
pass it in over here
it's our new hashmap
when it comes to designing the hash map
over here
I have to think about what the keys need
to be as always the keys need to be the
changing arguments through my recursive
method and here it's actually
interesting that two arguments change
right my amount changes because I have
some reduced sub amount that I'm passing
along and also my coin index changes
because from one call to the next it
would be increasing the coin index and
because those arguments change during
the recursion those are the ones I want
to encode into my hash keys right so
my keys here will actually be a list of
integer
I'll just make sure that that sub list
or those sub lists just contain a pair
of a Mountain Coin Index right
corresponding return value is going to
be integer so integer will be the values
of my map I'll call that my memo nice so
what I'm saying is I'll enter the base
case and I'll form my key I'll just say
list of integer it's going to just be a
list of the amounts followed by the coin
index I'm going to use this entire pair
as the keys in my memo so I'm going to
check if my memo contains a key a key
then I want to return its stored value
so return memo dot get key because that
means I've seen this is a problem before
so I can return the previously saved
subresult
and now what I want to do is make sure I
pass along this memo by reference
through the entire recursion
and also be sure to store your recursive
return value into the memo before you
leave so that would be line 31 here what
I do is I can say memo dot put you
always want to make the key for your
stored value the original key that
encodes the arguments right so a
Mountain Coin index are part of my key
here so I use that in my memo
and I store the total ways
then just be sure to return the old
value so return total ways all the same
right that shouldn't change
so with this let's go and give this a
test run we should now be using our memo
to solve this dynamic programming
problem quite quickly
see what we get
awesome and there we have it
hey programmers so you've reached the
end of a dynamic programming crash
course but the learning doesn't stop
here if you head over to structney.net
you'll be able to practice some dynamic
programming problems further we have a
full module on dynamic programming a lot
of the problems that you've covered not
in this video series for free code cam
but I have a lot more in store as well
so whether you're looking to really hone
in on your skills of dynamic programming
or you want to cover and go through all
the other topics we have featured on
structi I recommend you head to
structie.net you're going to have access
to video tutorials as well as animations
with me for every single problem I'll
see you there